Hey everybody,
all of you talking to you.
What's going on.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is one of our latest and greatest podcast sponsors and it's a very
interesting concept.
What they're doing is they're sending you ingredients,
fresh ingredients in like a cooler.
It's all chilled and shit and it's along with all the wars.
We're adjusting microphones here.
You good?
Uh,
they're sending you a cooler with all the ingredients for fresh meals along with
ingredients.
Uh,
they have these step by step instructions,
the recipe with visual instructions on how to create fantastic meals.
And here's how it works for $9 and 99 cents a meal.
And these are excellent meals.
They'll send you all the ingredients and the exact right proportions,
simple recipe instructions right to your door.
Meals are between 500 and 700 calories per serving and they,
it would,
when you're eating it,
you would think that it's a lot more because they're very delicious.
It's the yummy stuff that they've done it.
They've done a really excellent job and they've made everything completely idiot
proof.
That step by step instructions with pictures.
It's fun.
It's fun to do.
It's,
it's really,
I've enjoyed it.
I'm really getting a kick out of it.
And uh,
if you're interested in trying this,
go to blue apron.com/rogan.
That's blue apron.com/rogan and you will get your first two meals free by going
to that exact website.
Uh,
I love when someone comes up with a new concept,
like a completely different idea that I haven't heard before.
And uh,
this is one of them.
Uh,
poultry,
fish,
meat,
vegetables for like for this week I got oven fried chicken with corn and bean
salad,
shrimp,
lobster rolls,
lamb p and mint.
I can't even say this word or re charrettes.
How's that?
O.
R.
E C C h.
I.
E.
T.
T e only tell you something.
Blue Apron.
This is America.
Okay.
America.
We demand simplicity.
We don't want any fucking foreign names.
What does that as pasta or ketty pasta or Ketty.
Thanks so or Ketty they'll look right or Chetty or chatting,
whatever it is,
purple spring onions and lemons.
The point is this and does not bland food.
This is really like gourmet food that you can cook yourself and it's healthy and
it's low in calories and it's really excellent and the quality of their
ingredients.
I was pretty impressed by.
Uh,
I was looking at all the stuff like the cuts of meat,
the fish,
everything's super fresh and delicious and I love the idea.
Like a lot of us are super busy.
You don't have time to go to a store and buy a recipe book and then write down
all the shit that you need to buy and measure it out and weigh it out.
Blue Apron takes care of all the steps,
the shopping,
the,
the Wang,
the recipe,
everything.
And you can be insured of eating healthy meals and healthy meals that are fun to
make.
You can do it yourself and it's not hard.
It's easy to do.
I'm no chef.
I put them together.
And uh,
like I said,
it's quite yummy.
So give it a shot and I guarantee you will enjoy it.
Blue apron.com/rogan that's for two free meals,
blue apron.com/rogan we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n
n I t on it is a human optimization website and what we do is we sell you things
that we think can improve your mind and prove your body.
Anything that we can find that we use that helps physical fitness helps.
There's,
there's supplements that help endurance.
There's a,
there's a product called a quarter steps mushroom that shroom tech sport is
based on as one of my favorite supplements and I actually get really bummed out
if I go to the gym and I realized that I haven't had it,
I didn't put it in my bag.
Shroom tech is based on this mushroom that the Chinese Olympic team started
using and they were winning all these metals and the,
the idea behind the cordyceps mushroom is they found a long time ago,
these ancient cattle herders would,
they would go to high elevation.
They found that these cows would be noticeably more lively when they would be
eating the certain mushrooms.
And these mushrooms are cordyceps mushrooms.
In 1993,
the Beijing Summer Games,
uh,
the,
the Chinese long distance women's track team was running at a punishing full
marathon every day in preparation.
Several world records later and after extensive doping test,
everything came up negative.
And the coach,
coach Ma,
that's a real name revealed that it was cordyceps mushrooms,
cordyceps,
sinensis.
Um,
a lot of this stuff,
uh,
when it comes to,
you know,
any,
any grand claims,
uh,
a lot of this stuff is,
like understandably controversial.
And for that reason,
if you go to on it,
all of the supplements that we sell have a research pages for a,
all of them,
including all the links to peer reviewed studies based on all the different
individual ingredients,
whether it's for Alpha brain,
whether it's for shroom tech or any of the,
any of the supplements.
There's a reason why people use this stuff.
And it's not just anecdotal evidence,
not just based on personal experiences,
but there's actual science behind all of it.
So if you go read the stuff and check it out,
you'll,
you'll understand what we're talking about as far as fitness equipment.
We're selling the very best strength and conditioning equipment we can.
We're selling all this stuff that has been shown to Incruse increase what they
call functional strength,
functional strength meaning strength that you can use for a athletic endeavors.
Meaning it uses your whole body as an individual unit,
which is really where um,
strength and conditioning is in the 21st century.
He used to be a long time ago,
the people used to do a lot of isolation exercises like curls
and a lot of doing tricep extensions,
all these different things that would strengthen a particular muscle group and
you would do like back on Wednesday and then you would do buys and tries on
Thursday.
People don't really do that stuff anymore.
Now it's using your entire body as one unit.
And in doing so,
what you do is you teach your body how to move heavyweights,
how to do large amounts of work and how to do it in coordination.
So whether it's using sand bags that we sell,
whether it's using steel maces,
which is,
it looks like a weapon,
but it's really a,
just this large steel ball at the end of this long metal pipe and moving it
around is incredibly awkward and doing so you,
you use all these strange muscles and it's um,
it's really excellent as far as like a direct correlation between the work that
you put in the gym and physical performance in any athletic endeavor or just
having a stronger,
healthier body.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
end.
All supplements.
That's it.
That is the end of the commercials.
Aren't you happy?
I know you are.
Strap yourself in Lee's Gentlemen v Sauce from Twitter,
eight k a Michael Stevens is here and we're going to learn some shit.
Let's get cracking
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Hey man,
come on up to the microphone Fella.
Thanks for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
Awesome to be here.
Thanks for having me on.
Have you,
you got a killer youtube page man.
And um,
you know,
I love when I can find out about a youtube page.
Like if you go to some of your videos and you know,
you're like,
well what does this video,
and you go,
holy shit,
it's video's got 726,000 hits.
Other ones have millions.
What this one,
what if the earth stops spinning?
4 million to 185,279 hits,
which is just a testament to how fascinating these videos are and how
interesting.
And I think it's really cool that something that's educational and something
that people can learn from and it's,
it's you're,
you're getting incredibly popular because of it.
Yeah.
Isn't that amazing?
It's crazy.
For 4 million people wanted to learn about how the earth spun and what would
happen if it didn't.
It's not going to stop spinning,
but the physics behind
what if you were stopped spinning are fascinating and it makes you think about
the world and sort of appreciate the things you don't even think about.
Way More.
Yeah.
The physics of the spinning earth.
It's very bizarre when you stop to think that the idea,
all planets are constantly spinning in this weird way around a giant Sun and
this outer planets and they're all spinning and like that.
That's something that you don't think about on a day to day basis.
They did a basis,
he just,
you know,
just walk around and go to the mall and driving your car.
You don't think about it.
You're on a thousand miles an hour and a circle at all times.
Right.
And then on top of that,
the sun is revolving around the center of the galaxy even faster and our galaxy
is going around the center of a supercluster even faster.
In fact,
I think in the years,
Oh man,
either in the year 1600 or 600 I don't remember.
Earth was a light year away from where it is now relative to the center of the
galaxy.
Holy Shit.
It's traveled a light year that gets a loan that,
that amount of time.
It's either,
it's either,
I think it's 1400 years.
That's how long it takes the earth to travel a light year just by spinning
around with the son.
Where are we going around.
Yeah.
And hundreds and hundreds of millions of years we'll be back.
We'll be back in the same spot relative to the center of the galaxy.
But the galaxy will have moved,
right.
There is no absolute reference frame.
So the universe is expanding.
Yeah.
That's the other thing is there's maybe more than one universe.
That could explain some of the,
the,
you know,
things we still don't know yet.
There could be parallel universes where every other version of things happen.
And that would explain things like why we happen to see the universe that we see
now.
Why this one?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's when,
you know,
it's almost kind of stoner talk because it's one of those things like,
man,
try to wrap your head around that,
man.
But it is a fascinating concept that,
that we are in this essentially infinite universe.
I mean,
they've tried to put dimensions on the universe itself.
Like there's a,
there's an actual beginning and end to the university itself,
but the infinity comes from the concept that inside every black hole is
potentially another universe that every galaxy has a supermassive black hole.
It's one half of 1% of the mass of the entire galaxy.
And that inside that black hole,
it's very possible that there's a whole nother universe with hundreds of
billions of galaxies,
each with black holes inside of them,
each with new universes inside of them,
and that this fractal thing goes on and on and on and on,
and there's literally no end.
Yeah,
and I don't know about black holes,
but the universe itself,
we give it a dimension.
We give it like a circumference or diameter,
but that's just the observable universe.
We don't really know what's beyond what we can see and it could go on
infinitely.
It could also wrap back on itself and be sort of infinite and one way in one
sense.
But actually,
you know,
if you go far enough out,
you curve around like an ant on a globe,
that ant can just keep walking forward forever.
He'll eventually return to where he came from,
but he's never going to reach a wall,
an edge.
We think that's how our universe works.
Is it wrapping back around itself?
Well,
probably not.
We've been able to look really far away and we don't see any evidence of things
converging as if it's curving.
Yeah.
Like we're,
we're 3d creatures on this four d shape.
That wraps back around on itself.
Yeah.
The idea of the,
the universe having a finite amount of distance.
It's confusing as hell because then what's outside of the universe?
Well,
nothing.
Nothing.
So if it's finite,
then like where,
what's it sitting in?
Right,
exactly.
That's it's hard to wrap your head around and,
yeah,
and it does sound like stoner talk,
but it's also cosmology talk.
I mean,
it's a real science.
Real Science is stoner talk.
If you really get down to it.
Yeah.
If you ask enough questions,
it gets down to,
dude,
you're blowing my mind.
It's like,
no,
that really is just the way this pen stays on the table is incredible.
Yeah.
The Earth is spinning.
Atomic mass of the earth is pulling everything down towards it and the more mass
it has,
the heavier it will be and the more it'll stick.
I'm like,
what?
Yeah.
The subatomic level,
then things become magic.
Yeah.
And it's so sad that we're never going to see an atom there are too small.
Like they're smaller than the wavelength needed for us to like see them.
So we're never going to just be able to look at one.
I don't think it makes any sense to ask what color anatomy is there beyond
color?
They're just too small for it.
Too Small for color?
Yeah.
Is it too small for our perceptions of what color color is or no.
No,
they really are too small to trap light.
The way color works doesn't apply to Adams individually.
So even if we built like a super cool machine that,
that tried to be better than our eyes,
there's no color to see acting together.
Adam's can have a color obviously.
Would it be clear
if there's no color,
how would you observe it?
Like what would you see?
Would you see like wonder woman's plane?
Uh,
number one to one was playing was invisible.
It was invisible.
Yeah.
Had a lot of windows just didn't make any sense.
Like who the fuck is she drew flying around with wonder woman?
Didn't have just like a fighter jet.
She looked really corny.
Yeah,
she had,
she was like an economy.
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
but that's the thing.
There is,
there's no answer.
We don't know.
They're not that we don't know.
We just know that that doesn't apply.
And if that's the case,
okay,
if we can't see Adam's,
how do we know so much about subatomic particles?
Like what are we seeing when we're observing?
Right,
right.
I see.
You were seeing their effects.
For instance,
in the cloud chamber,
we can see individual particles because they interact with,
uh,
gas in the Chamber and cause trails and we can follow the trail and photograph
it and study it and say,
wow,
look how it moved because of it's a span or because of its,
you know,
the mass that we were able to detect.
It was probably a electron or whatever.
Right.
But we can't look at it and say,
Oh dude,
that was the same electron that I saw yesterday.
You know?
But if that's the case,
how do they understand what they're measuring?
Things like particles in super position,
which means a particle that it's moving and still at the same time.
How are they
doing that?
Look,
this is beyond my purview.
Clearly it's something that I'd love to learn more about,
but I think that it's not so much that we see.
Both were just like the only way to explain the way it behaves is that it was
doing both before we made the measurement.
Okay.
Do you think that they'll one day have more accurate measuring and they like,
oh my God,
we were so wrong.
It's possible.
Yeah.
It's more than one thing.
There's a famous,
yeah.
What about science being a graveyard of dead ideas,
right.
Yeah.
Thanks.
We were like,
oh,
obviously the earth is the center.
It seems that way and then someone goes up.
Oh,
actually,
that does create a problem,
doesn't it,
with educators.
Because if someone's been basing their entire life and their career writing
books,
teaching a certain principle that turns out to be completely and totally
incorrect at one point in time when new understanding come about,
what,
you know,
that that runs into human areas,
ego and weirdness when it comes to a,
what people are willing to,
uh,
to accept and not wanting to.
Sure.
But the point,
right
is not the facts.
It's the procedure,
the scientific method,
you know,
thinking scientifically and always basing these,
these,
um,
you know,
theories on things that we can experimentally test.
Right?
That's what matters.
And,
and if you can devise better and better tests,
you can learn more and more and be more and more sure of theories.
But you should always be more excited about conquering ignorance than just like
holding onto the,
the fact that you particularly liked or made up.
Yeah.
Most certainly.
You certainly should be.
But,
uh,
it is,
it's gotta be a real pain in the ass if you've spent your entire career teaching
something,
writing books on something.
And it turns out to be correct,
but that sort of comes with the territory.
Right.
I know,
and I've,
I've,
I actually,
I really want to do an episode at some point on like crazy things that people
believe that you would consider super smart.
Like Dh Lawrence,
the author,
he totally believed that the moon created light and refused to be convinced
otherwise.
Hmm.
Right,
right.
Uh,
not,
not because he was insane,
but because it was just like
we had an advanced science enough.
Right.
His science education was not great enough for him to go,
oh,
it's reflecting from the sun right there.
I'm sure there's all kinds of things like that.
Like William Shakespeare,
what did he know?
He didn't know anything about,
about
black holes.
Right,
right.
He knew less about black holes.
Then the dumbest person listening to this show right now,
you know?
Yeah.
Right.
No kidding.
Yeah.
It's,
it's really bizarre when you think about the fact that people had,
not only do they have like just a rudimentary understanding of the earth and its
position in the stars and the universe,
but with that rudimentary information,
they were able to circumnavigate the globe.
Yeah.
They were able to use those sextants and those like look at the stars and
measured distances and figure out where they were based on constellations and go
on the ocean in a fucking wouldn't floaty thing.
And just the wind
take them around a different yeah.
Dirt patches for years.
Yeah.
Hundreds and thousands of,
yeah.
You mentioned landing on a place where no one had been before and you're just
like,
well,
I hope we packed enough food.
Do you ever listen to radio lab?
Oh yeah.
It's great.
Great.
It's great cast.
They amazing an amazing piece on the Galapagos island recently.
Um,
and it's uh,
where Darwin sort of,
uh,
landed and PR partially where he formed his,
his theories about evolution and because it's such a,
just incredibly rich with diversity in different kinds of life.
But when they were talking about this really amazing,
and this is how little we understand about life and life's changes,
and they're,
they're seeing life changes right now.
They're seeing like the evolution of this new,
uh,
finch.
There's some,
some new bird is forming because there's a larger finch that's dying off and the
medium finch and the smaller fish are breeding and they're creating this new
finch and it's right.
And it's just unbelievably fascinating to think that all this is our point of
reference is,
you know,
a thousand,
a couple thousand years of people writing shit down and it's in the Greenwich
Spectrum of life on Earth.
It's not,
it's nothing.
I was thinking the other day about a recorded audio and how,
uh,
briefly earth and humanity have been able to record audio.
Yeah.
Uh,
and that brings up questions like,
what did George Washington sound like?
Yeah.
Right.
Did he have a British accent?
Well,
they say that British accents actually didn't evolve until much later,
and that the people that were in England in fact had a different accent in like
the 16 hundreds.
Yeah.
Then they have today.
Yeah,
that's true.
And I think,
you know,
you find the right experts,
they can perform for you.
These different accents not be not by,
uh,
the fact that they've listened to recordings.
They have it,
there aren't any,
but they can look at how words have changed over time and they can look at how
spellings of changed over time and come to a pretty good,
I see a pretty good conclusion about what a guy who lived in England in the year
600 sounded like.
What's really trippy is when they go to dead languages.
Yeah.
And they tried to recreate the sound of like ancient Sumerian.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I hadn't thought of that.
They're trying to figure out what it would sound like to hear like Gilgamesh
talk,
right.
They,
they have this sort of bizarre understanding.
I don't know.
I don't really get it.
I don't know how they could pull that out since nobody speaks it anymore.
I don't know how they ever figured it out anyway.
If you ever look at Cuny or form,
right.
I used to write back then,
A bunch of nails,
nails upwards and like old school nails,
like I used to do construction when I lived in Boston.
A lot of the buildings you would come across were really,
really old.
Yeah.
Like they were from the 18 hundreds and they used to,
the nails that they had back then were essentially handmade.
They weren't the nails that we see today with like the circular top and the
smooth,
uh,
the cylinder below at the smooth spike.
They were like,
you know,
kind of ledges my wedges.
And they were like crude and weird looking.
That's what cuneiform looks like,
right?
A bunch of cute crude little wedges up and down and sideways.
And they figured out how,
what that means,
what they were saying essentially with debate,
you know,
of course.
But they also are figuring out like what it sounded like when they were talking.
That's weird.
I get the,
I get the translation thing.
Uh,
the,
the Rosetta stone for instance,
really helped us go,
oh,
thank goodness they wrote the same thing in three different languages and we
know one of them or two of them.
Uh,
I don't know.
Um,
I have a lot of respect for people that can do that.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's also,
it's gotta be maddening.
There's a national geographic,
I think it's,
yeah,
probably pretty sure it's national geographic special called decoding the Maya.
It's all about Mayan language and trying to understand how difficult that is.
Another dead language essentially,
but a dead language that's in hieroglyphic form.
So images,
that means sounds,
you know,
so like,
um,
Mckenna described it best.
Like you would have like an eyeball assault,
like the cuts would,
you'd have an aunt like the bug and the flower,
like a rose.
And that's how you would say I saw aunt rose.
Okay.
Yeah.
This clever.
But that's,
that's,
you know,
that's how their language evolved.
Like our idea of,
I mean the,
is that,
that would be ridiculous.
Like without fuck,
don't you have letters?
Like can't you say Steve?
Where's Bob and Mike?
But in their culture,
you know,
that's what started and that's where it evolved and that's,
it grew out of that.
And is that going to happen to English someday?
I don't know what's going to happen with someday,
but I,
you know,
me and my friends were sitting around the other day and we were talking about
the idea of everything being on hard drives.
Yeah.
And how bizarre that is that if anything happened and for whatever reason,
you know,
a good percentage of the population died and everybody that was left was
computer illiterate.
How long would it take before we lost everything that anybody ever figured out?
I mean,
there wouldn't be much left unless somehow or another genetically that
information is stored or the revelations are somehow or another if there's a
large enough segment of the population.
But if not,
that shit's gone.
We have to leave instructions like here's how to play this blue ray.
Yeah.
It contains information and history of earth.
Well that's a thought that the people like Graham Hancock have when they stumble
across these gigantic monolith that nobody can explain like bowel back in
Lebanon and of course the,
this,
the pyramids in Egypt and all these just bizarre,
massive stone constructions that were not exactly sure how they put together.
I mean,
still to this day,
they look at the great pyramid and they just go,
well,
they may be,
we think that they kind of,
maybe the,
I dunno,
and they were made so long ago.
Yeah.
They weren't,
they're not like ancient Roman style.
Uh,
oldness it's way older than that.
I did,
I did a video on,
uh,
putting history in perspective and I've mentioned that the ancient Egyptian
pyramids were as old to the ancient Romans as the ancient Romans are to us.
There were,
there were wooly mammoths still alive when the pyramids were built in Egypt.
Oh yeah.
Was that true?
That's true.
Yeah.
On Wrangel island.
Well,
I thought woolly mammoth died out 10,000 years ago.
I don't,
I don't know when they died out or how,
we know
they died out of the pleistocene.
Right.
Didn't they?
I think woolly mammoths were a part of the great extinction event that they
think is connected to a asteroidal impacts.
Least some people do.
That's one of the theories.
Interesting.
Yeah.
All he knows that they were contemporaries,
the pyramids and woolly mammoths.
And I can't tell you the exact date that these all happen.
That's amazing.
You know what's even more trippy is these new discoveries like this go Beckley
TAPI thing that they're finding 12,000 plus years ago that they thought people
back then were just hunter and gatherers and they're finding these gigantic
carved stone columns with three d images of animals that are carved into it.
Meaning like you have a large stone and you cut the stone down,
but leave right off of a piece of stone that you could carve in a lizard.
Wow.
It's super complicated work.
And that the,
a lot of these lizards and animals aren't even native to the continent.
Turkey is,
you know,
we don't even think that these animals existed in the spot where this was going
on.
And at least the current knowledges that we don't think they existed there.
It's very,
very strange because they thought people were just hunter gatherers back then
and they built these massive,
like a concentric circles with 19 foot high stone columns.
Like they don't even know how to fuck they did it or who did it or what the
culture was,
and it's all new stuff over the last couple of decades found these and they're
older to have to the ancient Egyptians.
Then the ancient Egyptians are to us.
Wow.
Yeah.
By almost seven years,
seven,
7,000 years,
because they're 12,000 so the ancient Egyptians,
that's 2,500 BC,
they think they built the pyramids.
So these guys are 12,000 plus.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
It's not just incredible,
but they don't even know really how old it is.
They just know 12,000 years ago,
someone intentionally covered it up.
They've done like carbon dating on the soil and the soil is uniform like that.
The date of the soil is uniform,
which indicates to them,
I think this is how they do it,
that the
someone intentionally covered up this area.
Maybe like someone conquered these fucking chairs that were building these
awesome things.
Like these guys are assholes.
We need to go back to tents and cover all this crazy shit up.
So they filled it all in 12,000 years ago.
12,000 but humans have been around hundreds of thousands of million.
I mean,
yeah.
It's like I'll never meet those people.
Yeah.
Well,
and it's also the,
the,
just that number,
it's like just saying a thousand years,
this is like,
you put,
try to put that in your head,
you're like,
okay.
But if you could see it
a thousand years and a timelapse,
if he could see it run through a timelapse and then see like seven of those in a
row and then see like go Beckley tappy which is seven twice,
you know,
and just like just run through how much change must've taken place on this
planet and just one with his one bizarre life form that alters its environment.
Right.
The only one in,
in,
you know,
in such a grand scale.
Yeah.
It's crazy trying to decipher that those people like archeologists trying to
piece the past together.
That has got to be one of the most fastest.
Oh,
I know jobs ever.
Yeah,
I did.
I was reading about some of the oldest stuff we found is all about burial and
death,
but we haven't found so many,
just like homes,
like people's day to day lives weren't made to be nearly as permanent.
Death was so much more important than where you spent your entire life.
Yeah.
Especially when they didn't really,
I mean,
not that we understand what happens when people die today.
We just know they definitely die,
but we,
you know,
we don't,
we're still,
it's a lot of guesswork about what the process is of shutting off the soul.
If there is a soul,
whatever that life spark is that the consciousness where it goes,
does it go to the same place it goes when you're dreaming,
you know,
like what,
what,
what exactly happens.
But back then,
50% mortality rate for children if you're lucky,
you know,
everybody's getting eaten by animals and like,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think I was reading in a Jared diamond's book,
um,
that germs and steel guns,
germs and know is newer one he was talking or or way,
was that right?
Shoot?
I think so.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I was talking about how there are,
there are tribes that don't believe you're actually human until you're much
older than a baby.
Like babies are just kind of like almost have souls,
but not yet.
So if a baby dies,
it's like,
man,
wow.
Yeah,
it hasn't been initiated yet.
Or if you have too many kids you can just kill him cause they're there.
They're just like
not like a mirror.
Cats do.
Yeah,
maybe.
Right.
You just sit there and go,
wow,
there's a lot of diversity of,
of everything on earth.
Life and ideas will certainly,
yeah,
we
will.
We're,
we're big copycats.
You know,
we sort of imitate whatever the hell is going on around us if we have this idea
that babies aren't alive yet.
When you look at the horrible things that people were able justify doing
to others,
just because those others are,
you know,
thought to be an enemy or a subhuman because they're the enemy.
Yeah.
We're bizarre.
And is it this?
And it's,
it's when you really stop and think about what this bizarre behavior,
these bizarre behavior patterns people have and what they create like that they
create these cultures that vary wildly,
all human beings all on this planet.
But you know,
look at the difference between Palestine and Chicago.
Look at the difference between,
you know,
fill in the blank in Liberia,
in San Francisco,
look at the difference between London and,
you know,
Mongolia,
it's very strange how much things are different and how much they change.
But yet everyone's just a person.
Everyone can interbreed everyone can exchange ideas.
And once you take someone from that culture and bring them into yours,
they adopt those ideas.
If you took a baby from Nigeria,
brought them into,
you know,
whatever,
Atlanta and raised him there,
talk to them.
20 years later,
he's going to have an Atlanta accent.
He's going to have all the cops.
He's probably going to be into,
you know,
all the things that young kids are into and video games and young kids are into
wearing the clothes.
I mean,
he will look essentially entirely like an American kid.
Yeah,
yeah.
But humans aren't nearly as diverse as like dogs.
Right?
Dogs can come in huge,
have a huge variety of sizes and shapes and colors.
Uh,
and they can all interbreed it's all the same species,
but humans are pretty much all,
you know,
we fall within this general distribution.
Is that true though?
I,
I dunno.
Is it,
see,
I,
I want to make it clear that I have way more questions than answers.
Right.
I asked the questions and then try to find answers.
I don't know.
I could be wrong.
It could be like,
well,
Michael,
you know,
we all just think humans are all pretty similar because we know them so well.
Are we are them,
well,
a female dwarf,
a white female dwarf and Shaquille O'neal could have a baby.
How is that any different than then a chihuahua and a great Dane?
It's kind of similar,
the same difference.
It's kind of similar in a lot of ways.
There's so different looking Shaquille O'Neal and a,
a female dwarf.
Yeah,
they're very,
I mean,
assuming that the parts could fit right.
I mean that's about as far up.
I mean,
if you saw those two things and you'd be like,
oh,
those are totally different things.
Do you think he would?
I think so.
Totally different animals.
Yeah.
Well I like different specie.
Here's a perfect example.
An Eagle can't fuck a pigeon and have a baby.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
So Shaquille O'Neal and a female dwarf is a lot like an eagle and a pigeon.
Uh Huh.
I think we're going to have to do some experiments with the eagles and pigeons,
I hope.
Oh,
okay.
That's what I meant.
I meant the Eagle.
That's exactly what I meant.
Well,
you know,
that's the argument that the ancient alien guys use to the point to the fact
that human beings are genetically engineered because dogs were genetically
engineer
humans.
Yeah.
So their idea is that this is the proof that humans have been engineered and
that there's many versions of us and that,
you know,
there's been a bunch of different models that a crazy created and that's why we
vary so widely as opposed to every other animal that can breed.
Because hybrids in other species are usually sterile.
But hybrids with human beings,
like if you took Shaquille O'Neal and a white dwarf,
you would assume that's a hybrid,
you know,
you assume but they're not,
they're not.
It's the same race.
They totally like,
they're totally compatible as far as the way that you breed with them.
Right,
right.
Uh,
I,
I am being distracted by how much I have to urinate.
Oh,
go other day I was thinking about as just started man.
I know,
but I was not prepared.
I had water,
I drank a whole one of these.
Good.
And then I had hydrated stay healthy.
And I had a bunch of coffee this morning too.
But uh,
I was thinking yesterday,
this is related.
How much would you weigh if you never went to the bathroom?
You'd be dead.
How quickly?
It wouldn't take long.
I mean,
what if we had evolved to just not ever have to like a baby after just a month
would be bigger than the biggest human ever.
Don't think I need to do the math.
Well,
it depends on what you need to consume.
Like,
if your body was so efficient that you no longer needed to urinate,
like we kind of assume that your body would need to urinate,
but why?
If your body needs water to stay alive,
like what,
why are we assuming that it has to pull,
it has to get rid of waste that it doesn't want anymore.
Well why could,
could we just turn that into more hair instead?
But why does it have to get rid of waste?
Like isn't it possible that we can become so efficient that we no longer need to
get rid of waste and we can just sort of exist by breathing?
Right,
right.
Completely.
Just like self.
Yeah.
I mean to get to a certain size and once we get to a certain size,
we just,
you know,
whatever you evaporate off by walking around like that you have to take back in.
Right.
I guess,
you know.
Yeah.
Cause like they have,
you know,
robots that that just dissipate heat.
They don't have her make a waste product.
Your laptop doesn't create as much waste as a human,
but it's also not nearly as complex.
Uh,
but in some ways it's more complex.
They've been able to make machines that can poop.
You put food in and then it's got bacteria in different pumps and reservoirs
inside and it creates something that resembles completely and smells just like a
human dump.
Whoa.
The first one I saw was done as a piece of art as art work.
Like an artist created this machine that could poop just like a human.
And uh,
now they do it as they call it a robo gut.
It's actually a medical thing because when people have GI problems,
a poop transplant is commonly used to reintroduce the healthy bacteria and
taking from someone else and giving it to the sick person,
shoving it up.
There is kind of like,
you know,
there's a lot of possibilities for rejection,
infection,
stuff like that,
I guess.
But the Robo Gut can make just perfectly clean poop just with the kind that you
want.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You get some artificial poop put up inside of you to fix any imbalances that you
have in your gut flora that's fast and that crazy.
You can have like a poop farm of robot intestine,
right.
That are just,
and what do you feed them?
Yeah.
Digitally do burger runs for the robot guts.
And they totally are.
It's gotta be totally organic.
It's got a probably,
it's probably just like a paste or a liquid be like baby food.
You wouldn't have to taste good.
The robot's not going to complain.
Yeah.
Fuck that robot.
Just eat it,
bitch.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so this is making them go to the bathroom.
Oh,
go urinate.
There's a million subjects,
so don't worry about it.
You come back,
we'll have many,
many things talk about and uh,
congratulations.
You won the award for the quickest guy to p almost everybody.
Yeah.
It's right there on the right hand side.
Almost everybody has a point in time where,
uh,
the,
they,
they go,
oh,
this is,
how long has this podcast go?
Um,
I got you see that look on their face.
Like,
oh,
I think I have to pee.
But this dude he made Michael made it to 50 minutes.
That's not a lot of time,
but hey,
you gotta do what you gotta do.
I understand.
Yeah,
she is that his girlfriend?
Maybe ex girl.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
She's like five feet tall I think is that is why I think that's his ex wife
actually,
which is incredible that he was seven foot.
What?
How tall is it?
Seven one seven one 50 easily,
dude.
I did fear factor with him and uh,
I stand about penis high with him.
And uh,
when we were doing it,
it was like I was with my dad.
It was like I was with my giant black dad and he was standing next to me.
He did the countdown.
Oh,
it was fear effective for you or for you?
That's a big dude.
This guy,
Michael Stevens,
uh,
if you have never heard of him and a,
I are interested in this conversation,
his youtube page is fucking amazing.
It's really cool.
And a,
it's called tweet sauce or vsauce rather tweet sauce is his,
um,
his Twitter page and he's back.
I'm,
I'm s I'm thinking he's going to have to pick one more.
You think so?
I think I'm going to be fine.
I basically,
when I heard that you couldn't just cut it out like my pee break,
I got really nervous and I all of a sudden had to pee.
And to be fair there was a,
it was a very voluminous urination.
Like it wasn't um,
a nervous one.
It was a real one.
You might be the first guy I've ever heard use volume illness when it comes to
urination.
Oh I use it all the time.
Every time.
No,
no,
I do get concerned.
I'm like,
am I peanut enough?
Cause I've said I've,
I've peed um,
next to other guys like you know,
in different urinals.
Right.
And I can tell that like they're going a lot longer than me and the sound that
it's making,
it's just so much like the flow is so strong and it must contain so many gallons
of,
and I'm like,
do you just hold it longer?
Is your bladder bigger than mine?
I'm very insecure about how much Ip I feel like it's not impressive.
Depends on where you are.
If you're at a bar,
those guys are probably drinking beer.
And if you're drinking beer,
you're going to pee massive oddity,
right?
It's coming out hard and you probably having a conversation with somebody and
you're holding it in for a while and then when you do let it go,
yeah,
yeah.
Waterfall.
Yeah,
that could be a while.
I was peeing.
I did think of something that kind of wraps up the whole first part of this pre
p conversation and again goes back to Jared diamond who said,
uh,
he tells a story about,
um,
Europeans first meeting a tribe in Papa New Guinea.
And of course if you're this tribe and these guys show up using technology and
materials you'd never seen before and they look very different and they dress
very different,
you might think that they're gods,
that there are different types of animal.
Um,
and I think they thought they were gods until two things happened.
One,
the tribe realized that the Europeans pooped and it smelled just like theirs.
And secondly,
they could have sex.
Those two things solidified the fact that they were all humans together.
Wow.
Yeah.
They had different types of weapons.
They had a different way of speaking and dressing,
but there were things about them.
Those two things that really made,
made both sides realize we are the same animal.
Wow.
Yeah.
Can you imagine being someone who lives in some sort of a tribal environment in
the middle of the Amazon and all of a sudden a plane lands,
you know,
on the water and people come out and you're like,
what the fuck is this?
No one's ever seen another PR,
especially a white person that has gotta be akin to an alien.
Oh,
it is.
It is.
And it's,
it's a kinda been visited by a god as well.
So look up the cargo cults.
I don't remember what part of the world they live in,
but,
uh,
during,
I think during a war,
airplanes were coming in and out and these tribal people didn't know what they
were.
They,
they,
we still don't exactly know what they're thinking or what they were.
But,
uh,
the plane stopped after a while.
The war was over.
And to this day they have recreated,
I'm serious.
They've recreated using materials that they find around where they live a runway
and all the things that they associate with,
whether they built a little airplane out a wood trying to get it to come back.
Yeah.
Von Daniken.
Use that as an argument in chariots of the Gods and explain that,
uh,
this is one of the reasons why,
you know,
these depictions of what could be interpreted as flying saucers and all these
shares and modern art.
That's,
that's what it is.
It's like the long lost information passed down generation to generation of,
at one point in time we were,
were visited by something from somewhere else and it sounds that's a,
one of those subjects where as soon as you open up the possibility of that,
you say like,
well we,
maybe we were visited,
but you like,
oh,
just fucking Christ.
He's one of those guys.
Like it's an immediate reaction.
I have it.
It's like when someone starts talking to me about the possibility of humans
being visited,
extra terrestrials coming here,
right.
Manipulating our DNA.
And we were okay.
All right,
I got you.
That's,
that's fine.
But I would like for them to show me experiments they've devised that'll give us
evidence for that.
Otherwise,
it's not falsifiable.
Right.
I could say,
dude,
you know that there's a blue rhinoceros on some planet that's billions of years
away.
Seriously?
Well,
there might be,
yeah,
there might be.
There might be aliens might have created the pyramids,
right?
Probably not though.
Well,
they don't,
I don't,
I
think there's anyone credible that thinks that aliens created the pyramids.
Um,
but would they do think is that they created people and that they did some sort
of a genetic manipulation.
Right,
right.
Things.
And when I say credible,
like credible,
I mean,
what does that mean?
You know,
there's no evidence whatsoever.
None.
I did this show for something fun.
Fiction though.
That'd be an awesome movie.
Well,
that's that the whole base of prometheus's yeah.
That we were somehow or another engineer,
the engineer's came down right here.
And that's,
uh,
you know,
when you talk about Sumerian texts,
we were talking about that earlier.
That was the whole premise of this guy's Zechariah.
It's worth work.
They've ever heard of that guy.
It sounds very familiar.
Oh,
he's the king of all those,
uh,
people who are into wacky shit.
Zacharias Hitchens,
the king.
Okay.
Because he believed that the Sumerian text,
um,
if you deciphered it correctly,
approves that we were engineered by something called the Annunaki and that the
Annunaki,
the literal translation of auto as those from heaven to earth came,
meaning that it was,
uh,
the same as the Elohim from the Bible.
Right.
That,
you know,
these,
these beings came from another planet,
genetically altered human beings and he points to these various images that
were,
um,
in the Sumerian text and Sumerian cuneiforms and all these different stone
carvings that show what looks like the double helix of DNA.
Um,
uh,
sure,
sure.
The caduceus,
you know,
the two snakes that are wrapped around the pole that we associate with medicine,
that he interprets that as being,
uh,
an an,
an image of the Double Helix Dna,
right?
Coincidence too.
It could be,
yeah.
But it does look a lot like it.
Right.
You know,
the double helix and the,
the two snakes wrapped around a pole,
but the weirdness is the,
the pictures of like,
there's one that shows a,
one of these,
uh,
auto knocky with a,
looks like a person with a tail sitting on his lap and they interpret that as
being like this idea that they took sub human primates and manipulated the DNA,
adding alien DNA creating.
It's just incredibly bizarre stuff.
But what gets me is,
yeah,
absolutely ridiculous.
Yeah,
probably not right.
Most people,
and there's also a website called Cichon is wrong,
where other,
sure.
Other scholars who have studied the cuneiform and studied the Sumerian texts
completely disagree with his interpretations.
But if we could travel to another planet and we could do it successfully,
and we've done it,
you know,
for thousands and thousands of years and southern planet is,
whey the fuck and the other side of the galaxy and we find some primates.
I don't think it's outside the realm of possibility that we would manipulate
their DNA
there.
There are actually protocols already in place,
not officially adopted by any government,
but protocols about what do we do if we discover life because we,
uh,
most likely would contaminate it by trying to observe it.
I think that there,
there are even people arguing right now that Mars has been contaminated by the
rovers,
by the rovers that have gotten there.
I mean,
we,
we've found,
I think staph bacteria,
uh,
on the moon that had been sent to the moon when we visited because we didn't
completely sterilize everything.
Thank you.
Someone touched,
excuse me,
someone touching the object.
The object went to the moon,
right?
Someone observed that staff being on the object living on the,
wow.
It wasn't living on the moon,
but it was just,
it was transferred there.
Yeah.
Um,
and so that's a huge problem.
well just space junk itself.
Just the idea of the rover being on Mars.
I mean,
if another life form visited Mars landed there and found the rover,
they'd be like,
okay,
what the fuck is that?
Right.
And this brings up the whole question of kind of space archaeology or like space
preservation.
So the,
the,
um,
the stuff Neil Armstrong used to like get to the moon and walk around,
it's all still there.
Right?
So if we ever start regularly going to the moon,
do we set up a museum there?
Do we put fences up around it?
Who owns that landing site?
Well,
your name was supposed to fly over those sites.
Right.
And then didn't they,
the,
they made some sort of a ruling that any future space flights should not take
place over those sites.
I didn't hear about that.
Yeah.
I think they're worried about people fucking it up,
you know?
I mean,
look,
if we,
if space travel becomes like as easy as at one point in time,
getting across the country was a fucking heroic event.
You know,
when the pilgrims landed and you had the,
I was watching this show last night,
that was,
um,
it was all about the wagons that they used to traverse the land to get from the
east coast to the west coast.
Yeah.
Amazing stuff.
Because,
you know,
we have like leaf spin springs and certain cars,
they had them that they had made out of leather,
like they had concocted these sort of suspension cells,
these adjustable manipulate,
you know,
the,
so they would move a little bit as they went over rocks and stuff and they had
done all this stuff out of leather and is,
it's just so strange to think that there were people that had put their life in
their faith and they had,
you know,
some goods in the back,
they have some food and they were hoping to find things to eat along the way,
but it's going to take you fucking forever.
Yeah.
Now you get an a plane.
And then I got,
uh,
I got uh,
La Flight I got to catch.
Um,
so,
uh,
I land at noon,
I'll call you.
Love you ma.
Can I kids see a,
yeah.
Daddy will call you when he lands,
what?
You just get in a plane.
I mean that 200 years ago,
insanely preposterous.
So different.
The idea is one day,
200 years from now,
whatever it is,
it'll be that easy to get to the moon.
So they're putting these protocols in place like,
Hey,
don't go there and just steal shit,
steal it or yeah,
take a rental home with you.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Lucy Kay is a great joke about that.
He's like,
you used to be to go across the United States.
It took so many years that people died.
People were born.
It was a whole different group of people.
By the time you finally got your destination,
this,
this is the Louis C k joke,
and now it's just like you get in a plane and you're done.
You know,
when Elon Musk finishes these crazy high speed rails,
then it's going to be like an hour.
Oh,
it's crazy.
An hour to get to New York from here,
just show,
just taking off on some crazy magnetic rail system and virgin galactic as well,
right?
They,
they'll get into like the sub orbital,
um,
uh,
I guess tracks and uh,
you can go from here to Australia in just a matter of minutes.
They orbit to in the International Space Station.
They orbit around the earth 17 times a day.
God,
so yeah,
so crazy.
They have 17 sunrises and sunsets every 24 hour period.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
That is amazing.
That's booking it.
That is so crazy.
So it's so a little less than every two hours.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fucking a,
and that's just the beginning.
You know,
a thousand years from now,
if we stay alive and don't blow each other up,
it'll be even easier to do that.
Yeah.
And people will say,
man,
remember back when people used to orbit the earth only 17 times every 24 hours.
This is another,
and I don't remember the comedian who told this joke,
but he's like,
in the future,
like everything's gonna be so fast.
It's going to take like two seconds to go everywhere.
But the DMV,
man,
it's going to take nine seconds and we're all going to hate it.
That's so true.
That is,
is going to be very strange.
I think it is very strange now when you,
you,
you know,
it used to be if someone showed up on your border,
no matter where you were,
it was usually a fucking problem.
You know,
if a boat pulled up like very rarely where people just super cool and you know,
you're not worried about it.
But today there's a thing called tourism,
right?
And it's a huge part of life.
I mean a huge part of life in,
in various cultures is people showing up and bringing with them money and uh,
they,
you know,
you welcome them part of the economy of the area,
right?
It's very strange how just that ability to traverse distances has changed the
way human beings interact with each other.
And it's also made the idea of countries and nationalities and your loyalty to
those countries and nationalities a little bit more ridiculous.
Every year a little bit more ridiculous.
The closer we get to this ability to instantaneously travel from one place to
another,
like these borders,
he's selfimposed borders.
Like the border between Mexico and the United States is probably one of the most
egregious.
When you stop and think about the,
the,
the difference in prosperity between like,
yeah,
you know,
Juarez and Los Angeles,
Tijuana and San Diego.
It's like,
fuck man.
Like that's crazy that a third world country is right there.
These poor people are starving to death and we won't let them come across this
little imaginary line where everything is wonderful and everybody's fat,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
and people often say like,
aw,
but dude,
when you're like,
look down on the earth from outer space,
you don't see borders,
but you do the border between India and Pakistan is lit up so brightly.
You can see it from space.
What is it like?
Is it like,
uh,
like their,
their borders at like a fence?
Like he's like the Great Wall of China.
Yeah.
Parts of it.
Parts of it are just,
I think,
yeah.
Fenced off,
militarized lit up and,
uh,
I,
I've covered a few other borders that you can see from space in the past.
I'm not remembering them at the moment,
but it's like we've,
you could look down from Earth and tell that we don't all get along.
My friend Ari that you see behind you right there on the or above you,
that photo.
Um,
Ari just got back from doing a tour of China and I took some photos of himself
on the Great Wall.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I'd read that you could see the Great Wall from space.
Apparently I can't,
but when he was,
uh,
there,
you know,
we were talking about the Great Wall and he was saying how fucking crazy it was.
So then I started looking up the Great Wall and it's 5,000 miles long.
It's a great wall.
That's not a good wall.
Yeah.
I mean,
that really is a great wall.
That's a funny joke by the way.
I would,
if there's a,
uh,
a wall in China,
people call the good wall.
China.
It's all right.
I mean,
it's,
it keeps the ceiling up.
It's pretty good.
Bar's been set.
So high,
good wall would have to be a few thousand miles.
You know,
the good wall would have to be like 2000 miles.
Right,
right.
You know,
what is that picture,
Jamie?
He pulled up,
yeah,
Pakistan border.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Wow.
About 2000 kilometers long.
It's insane,
right?
Yeah.
You could see that border.
That's legit.
That's a line.
It's a highway is what it is.
This is what it looks like from the ground.
Really?
Wow.
How fascinating to people look similar live right next door.
Hate each other,
have nuclear weapons pointing at each other at all times.
Yeah.
My friend Shane Smith,
the,
uh,
he runs vice.com he's been to Indian,
Pakistan,
and he says that is the one place where he's most terrified of a nuclear war
breaking out.
Oh,
for sure.
Osama bin Laden was in Pakistan.
It's,
it's crazy.
You know,
I was just in Mumbai and at the airport,
a plane came in and it was from Iran.
I on airlines and I'm like,
wow,
you don't see that in America.
They're not allowed to land there.
But,
but I actually went over,
just watched the people getting off the plane.
I was like,
hey,
fellow humans that I would never run into unless this happened.
Also the fact that,
um,
to go from,
I went from Washington DC to Mumbai,
uh,
we flew over Iraq and Afghanistan and I'm like,
Whoa,
I didn't know we did this.
And then after what happened in the Ukraine,
I'm like,
that's crazy.
I felt like I was safe up there at 30,000 feet flying over,
um,
the earth,
but apparently not.
What exactly has happened?
Are they sure that these were blown up by missiles and not by bombs?
I haven't,
I haven't been following the story well enough.
Last I heard it was fired from an antiaircraft,
um,
weapon from the ground.
So I didn't know they could do that.
I know 30,000 feet in the air.
I didn't know that he would hit that.
And just a few weeks before that happened,
I was reading some article I found on dig that was all about,
uh,
you know,
airport security keeps us from bringing things on the planes,
but the real ness next threat is what people can do to planes from the ground.
And I was like,
no way.
But then if you're going to be in and out burger that's near that,
uh,
this near lax,
there's a great view of the planes coming in and they are close you.
Oh yeah.
Once,
especially when they're taking off.
Yeah.
That's so true.
No one's doing any security to keep you from putting a fucking antimissile or
anti aircraft.
The slingshot,
honestly,
there's so close.
What kind of slingshot that you,
Karen?
Well,
maybe I'm exaggerating,
but not really.
If you break the window,
right.
I mean,
could you break a window or shoot it into a turbine,
you know?
Oh,
you know,
but they also had problems with that laser pointers.
People pointing,
laser pointers,
it planes.
And that can be dangerous for pilots.
Yeah.
Why not pilots like essentially running almost entirely on autopilot these days?
I don't know.
All right.
Either.
Obviously not.
Obviously they've got some control over what,
yeah,
they certainly have some control,
but yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of like,
we were so funny when we isolate threats.
Like,
I was thinking this
the other day while I was traveling,
you know,
we were going through the airport and you know,
they're going through all your shit and they're scanning you and you're putting
your hands over your head and the radio thing checks your body for weapons and
you go through and you get the clear and you go.
But it's only the airport.
There's this places where people congregate in by the thousands and there's
virtually no security whatsoever.
Like malls.
When was the last time nobody checks shit at the mall.
You go to the parking lot.
It's filled with cars.
Yeah.
Times Square.
You go walk through.
There's thousands of people in these malls.
Uh,
whenever I passed that security,
you know,
body scan screening,
I feel really good.
I really,
I feel like I did it.
I passed.
Am I the only one?
I just,
I really loved that experience of like,
I put my hands up,
the thing goes,
and then I stand there and the guy's like,
wait.
And I'm like,
I'm clean,
I promise.
Then he hears it and he goes,
you can go ahead.
And I'm like,
I did it.
I get credit for being not a threat and I love it.
Why do you love me?
I don't know.
I think I'm a pleaser,
right at heart.
I just want people to enjoy me and be happy with me.
So walking through a metal detector and not having it go off.
Oh,
I just could do that all day
if there's someone there watching going,
Yup,
you're good,
you're good.
That's an interesting admission ambassador to you don't feel this.
It's not just relief.
It's like pride.
No I don't.
I definitely don't feel pride.
I definitely feel a slight relief.
Like,
okay,
this is over.
Sure.
Cause I don't like the whole process.
I'm not a criminal and I'm not a threat.
I'm not a terrorist and I don't have any plans on ever being one.
So when I'm doing this,
I'm like,
this is just so crazy that this tiny minute one,
100th of 1% of the population,
if it's even that you ever have to worry about it.
It's probably not even that statistically,
you know,
look,
1% of the population means out of 100 million,
you have a million people,
right?
That's 1% yeah.
So it's not that.
So it's not that it's not evil.
It's very,
very,
very small what the actual threat is.
But because of these fuckheads,
these actual threats,
everyone has to be massively inconvenient.
Yeah.
So I find it to be incredibly inefficient,
ridiculous,
and almost,
it almost sort of in forces,
this idea of instability because although 99.999999999% of people are nothing to
worry about because there is this minute tiny threat.
Everyone has to be inconvenienced.
Everyone has to be a suspect,
and you have to be treated by these.
You know,
these people that are getting paid very little money in high stress situations,
they're not experts.
It's sociology or psychology rather.
They're not,
you know,
they're not experts in how their,
their,
their behavior impacts people who are being treated like,
yeah.
That,
that a job like that is fascinating.
I want to do a documentary someday about people who,
their job is to do something that everyone hates me.
Like a meter maid did.
Was there a movie about meter maids and what it was like to just be like,
all right,
time to start my job,
which literally is just being hated all day.
Same with people who work at complaint departments.
Well,
I worked as a security guard once for a concert venue and um,
you develop this us versus them mentality.
I only did it for a summer and just over the course of the summer,
because we were,
one of the things that we did was people were always trying to sneak in bottles
of booze.
The concert venue sold booze,
but obviously they were in paper cups and plastic cups.
Right.
But people would try to bring in bottles of wine,
like James Taylor concert.
Like we,
we busted more people with bottles of wine.
This James Taylor concert because everybody was trying to sneak them in their
purse,
right?
And we would check,
they'd be like,
no,
there's nothing in here.
And be like,
we have to check your purse.
Right?
Like,
why do you have to check my purse?
Because you might have a bottle of wine in there and they'll,
how do you know I have a bottle of wine because everybody has a fucking bottle
of wine.
It's a James Taylor concert.
Or you know,
like we're just going to come in and just have it,
nope,
can't do it,
but this is expensive.
Well,
go home and once you pass through that border,
right,
you can't bring it back,
you know,
it's over.
And um,
we would,
we would get these people that would be really angry at us,
like,
and real confrontational and how to add al just,
you know,
three months of me working there,
you,
you develop this mentality where you like,
you know,
the fuck these people,
these people were assholes.
Like,
and that's just us versus them.
It just people,
right?
But because you're the one whose job is to enforce it and they're angry at you,
you develop this very conf confrontational relationship.
Yeah.
It was very weird and I noticed it.
It was super unhealthy and I decided after the one summer,
they're like,
I'm never doing this again,
but someone has to do that job.
Do they though?
Good question.
I don't know if they do.
You know,
I do not know if someone really needs to do that job.
I think,
um,
first of all,
if you just say don't bring any bags,
like what's the worst thing?
Someone bringing in a flask and they're gonna start a riot where everybody pulls
out their flasks and throws them at the same time and you know,
falls from the sky.
These fucking,
I don't know.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know.
But the job sucks.
Yeah.
And everywhere you go,
people were trying to get over on you and everywhere.
And that's minor.
That's just,
most of the people weren't bringing in stuff.
It was,
you know,
a small percentage,
and that,
that is that there's a distinction between that job and I'm working at a
complaint department where the complaint department,
maybe you're helping people with the problem they're experiencing,
but if all you do is stop people from bringing in the bottle of wine that they
want to have theirs,
you never,
you don't like work with them to make it work.
Yeah.
Good point.
That's a really good point.
Yeah.
Complaint departments,
they fucking hate it.
People hate it.
You know,
they hate that Gig.
Yeah.
I'm a Meta.
May would be the worst,
I think,
or one of the cops are one of the worst.
I always tell people like,
you know,
there's people like fuck cops.
I hate cops.
The cops are just people.
Okay.
People can vary.
They can be wonderful and they can be terrible.
And the,
if you imagine what it would be like if almost everyone you talk to is a to you,
almost everyone you talked to is in the middle of a crime that they don't want
you to figure out there in the middle of a crime.
Everyone's speeding and their lot.
I didn't know I was speeding.
Like you're just dealing with liars all day or you have you been drinking
certain,
no,
dude,
you fucking smell like alcohol.
Get out of the car ass all and you just like enough,
you're tired,
tired of your life being threatened by these people.
You're tired of the having to enforce these laws and nobody wants to listen and
they develop.
They're the worst to developing this US versus them mentality.
You think about 20 years as a police officer and all the,
the,
your perception of people,
you know,
it would be like asking a proc tologist what,
what asshole smell like.
Right.
You know,
like you're only dealing with people with like asshole problems,
you know?
Yeah,
exactly.
it's human beings are very bizarre man.
We're very bizarre.
And our solutions for dealing with issues oftentimes create new issues.
And I think that is most certainly the case with the TSA.
And I think that's most certainly the case.
The police,
I think w are,
are ways of handling things,
create greater issues.
Did I talk about humans all the time?
And I often compares to animals and animals don't have any of these problems or
do they?
But they would.
They would.
What if,
what if they could lie,
right?
Can a dog lie?
If they could,
they'd be lying like a motherfucker.
Could you imagine if a dog ate your steak?
Like if you put a steak on the counter and the dog ate it and you like,
did you eat my stag?
He's like,
no,
no.
Right.
No food.
But if a dog could talk,
could it lie?
That's one of the biggest problem with comparing the humans and animals is that
we can't ask the animal questions and get feedback from them.
We have to just think,
well,
the dog ate the steak and now he's,
you know,
involved in some other act dog activity.
But how does he lie?
Because I can't ask him if he did it or not.
Ken,
it can a dog be deceptive.
Right?
And you could maybe teach a dog that like if you,
if you cover this thing up,
I won't know,
but is the dog actually intending to cover it or does the dog just know that
this action means this result?
Right?
Is it lying?
And,
and that's a fantastic question.
It is,
uh,
do they have the capacity for deception,
right?
Is that a complex?
What's really fun is trying to figure out how to even test it.
How can I prove that this dog can lie?
Right?
That's a very difficult,
and we still haven't been able to do it.
Well,
here's one.
Yeah.
I don't think they can lie,
but cats,
when a cat is creeping up on a bird,
aren't they lying?
I mean,
they're being deceptive.
There's slowly
moved.
Cause they don't want you to perceive that they're there.
That's a great point.
There's clearly a lot of deception in the animal kingdom.
Camouflage shorts,
but a Venus fly traps,
even in the plant world,
this is just a beautiful flower snap.
Right?
This jail I'm going to eat you.
Here's another question.
If I took a monkey like that was in the jungle,
right.
And I time traveled him back 8,000 years and I put them back in that same jungle
with other monkeys.
Be Like what?
You're of monkey from the future.
You're so different.
Maybe not 8,000 but maybe half a million,
half a million.
Sure.
But if I took you and sent you back just 200 years,
you would be from the future and it people would freak out.
I would run shit,
you would run it,
but no,
no,
no.
I would munch shit.
Does monkey culture,
does dog culture change at the same speed?
Right.
With the dogs be like,
ah,
whatever.
It's the year 10,000 BC.
It's fine.
Dogs are still dogs,
but humans can't time travel and fit in that well.
Well there's so many
less variables in the dog world because they don't communicate.
They don't have a database of information that drawing from that I've languages.
So the difference between a person of 200 years ago and a dog from 200 years
ago,
I think a dog would be exactly the same 200 years ago.
I don't think there would be,
of course,
different breeds,
you know,
like that people have engineered.
Sure,
sure.
Pit Bowls and poodles that wouldn't exist 200 years ago that have been,
I mean,
I have a dog,
it's called a regency mastiff and it's a massive,
that's been engineered by a friend of mine and he actually took a bunch of
different types of dogs and he bred a smaller mass if that's more athletic.
Wow.
And he also made sure that these dogs are,
have no dog aggression,
no people,
aggression.
Like this is sweetest dog ever.
Like my,
my three year old would just go up to it and grab it and grab her arms around
his neck and he would kiss her.
And it's like,
I never worry about this dog.
He's the sweetest and it's because he was engineered,
but in engineered over the course of a couple of decades by a friend.
Yeah.
So I know like the whole lineage.
I know how it all started.
It's really,
really fascinating.
Dogs or technology and a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't have the database.
Like if you could go back 200 years ago,
you would be the wizard of the future,
you know,
how many years do you have what you have in your head?
I mean with you,
what you've accumulated and when you're,
if you could go back in time with the fucking iPad and your vsauce um,
videos on youtube,
my God,
you would be one king maybe.
But could I convince people?
Uh,
just,
just knowing,
um,
something about the moon doesn't mean that they're going to believe me.
And that's,
that's one of the things people don't think about when they imagine being the
king.
If they could travel back in time.
Is that,
sure.
You could explain to people that where you're from,
everyone has a cell phone,
but could you invent one for them?
No.
Could you put a satellite up into orbit?
No,
but you could explain that in the future.
People will put things into orbit.
But would you know more about how to get something into orbit than just some
random guy from the year 1200?
I certainly wouldn't,
but some people would.
You probably would.
Well,
I certainly know more than I would,
but you would wait.
You would know way more than they would.
They would have to listen to you if you had an iPad.
They'd fucking for sure know how helpful I'd be.
I wouldn't know what kind of propelling us to use.
I would just be like,
we need something strong enough to escape Earth's gravity.
And they'd be like,
well,
okay,
but what is that?
And I'm like,
well,
I don't exactly know.
I know that,
uh,
the space shuttle had a liquid fuel and it's tank and it had solid fuel and it's
solid rocket boosters,
the SRBs.
And they'll be like,
okay,
but what is the fuel made of?
I'm like,
I don't know.
Where do we get the fuel?
Well,
you kind of have an understanding of explosions and propellant and things that
are flammable,
but does that mean that I could build a rocket?
Can I explain to a,
uh,
a cultured how to make one?
Well that's one of the cool things about human beings is that we,
we work on each other's work totally.
And without like they're,
you know,
Obama came under a lot of criticism for this whole,
uh,
you know,
you didn't build it thing like if you built a small business,
you didn't bill,
you didn't build that infrastructure,
you didn't build those.
But that is kind of,
it was,
I don't think he was eloquently put and it left open a lot of room for counter.
But the reality of it is every single thing that any human being has invented
only took place because someone invented the ability to communicate some of the
village uh,
invented education.
Someone invented a society that's civil enough that you could think and,
and pontificate on these things and not have to worry about the barbarians
coming over the hills with fucking spears.
Like all of this only takes place because all,
I mean,
the only reason why you can build a rocket,
it's cause someone built alloys because someone filled out fit,
figured out propellant cause someone figured out,
contained explosion because someone figured out velocity and speed and how much
energy you actually have to have to escape the energy of gravity pulling you
down and all those,
the,
the pull of the earth and then the,
you know,
the resistance of air and all these different variables.
There had to be untold number of people that had figured these things out before
you came along with your next step.
Right?
Right.
So how valuable would I be to people in the past?
I feel like I'd be most valuable when it came to just like all the jokes that I
know that comedians made up in between the past and now.
But I don't know how helpful I'd be about just like,
oh,
you guys didn't know there's a better way to grow corn.
Like we,
like corn is really cheap,
uh,
from where I'm from.
And they're like,
okay,
but how do you grow that?
And I'm like,
well,
I don't know exactly how they do it.
You guys know about Monsanto.
Will they make a,
you know,
special seeds that,
uh,
their,
you know,
their pesticides will own,
will not kill,
just do that.
And
then I'd be like,
what's a pesticide?
And I'm like,
well,
I don't know.
It's like a chemical that,
that kills pests.
And they're like,
well great.
You're just making up fictional stories.
Right.
I can do that too if the cars fly.
There you go.
Cause I mean,
you can build one over time though.
Be able to explain enough that you'd be completely fascinating.
Um,
I was watching a documentary recently about locust,
about the,
uh,
various times throughout history where locus and filled the sky like clouds of
locusts.
And it was about the old west and,
uh,
the army being brought in to deliver food to these poor people that had a,
that lived in,
you know,
the 1800 or 1700 or whatever the fuck it was.
But they had these black and white photos of the army and then they're bringing
in these,
these wagons filled with food and these poor people there.
Their crops just been completely devastated by these these things that just
showed up.
I'll fill the sky,
these grasshoppers and you know,
if you could go back and talk to those people and explained pesticides and shit
and like this is a,
what we need to do is find the root cause of the problem and find these bugs and
keep them from,
from breeding and like they'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like pesticides,
what is that?
Well,
it's chemical that you spray on and keeps the
right that's from many food.
Like cooking.
Like if I went back to before there was pizza,
I could probably still make a pizza because as long as bread had still been like
invented and there was cheese and meat,
I could combine them in the right way to make a pizza.
I Dunno how to make exactly make pizza dough from the Greens had have back in
the past.
But that could blow people's mind.
If I made a really delicious pizza
hug,
be hard to get yeast.
Where do you get used?
Uh,
from the store?
See,
that's the problem.
And this was really well put in a show called connections,
um,
that there was on television a long time ago.
Uh,
in the very first episode.
The guy's like,
what if everyone on earth disappeared?
What would you do?
And everyone's like,
oh,
I know what I do.
I'd like,
you know,
find a farm and I could grow food.
And he's like,
really?
You could grow food.
When do you plant these seeds?
How far down the,
you'd plant them?
And everyone goes,
oh,
okay.
Nope.
I don't know.
Well,
you,
it would probably be able to figure out a lot of shit.
You know,
if you had a farm,
if you had a,
well,
if you had animals,
you would PR,
you're a smart guy.
He'd probably be able to get out a lot of shit.
You'd definitely make some errors,
but you'd be able to figure out a lot of shit.
I think you're right.
Yeah,
you're right.
The real part problem would be reengineering,
you know,
the,
the really complex stuff like communications networks.
And that would be mean.
That would be over.
I mean,
if,
if it was only up to,
you know,
if you could get a random group of a hundred people just completely random and
they wouldn't be the only people that survive,
we would be caveman.
I mean,
we literally,
if
we,
if you only had a hundred people and we removed all of the technology we have
today and the hundred people had to move forward and progress just based on the
information that they have inside their heads,
fuck,
good luck.
We in.
That's the weird thing about the human organism.
It really is a giant super organism that needs to itself.
Yeah,
that's right there.
There are definitely people you would want to be in that group of hundred and
people that you wouldn't,
wouldn't be nearly as helpful.
Sure.
But we need a balance each other out.
Maybe the people that were in that group,
maybe they had some great ideas scientifically,
but maybe they were fucked up socially.
Um,
maybe they couldn't deal with having the responsibility of being the Alpha,
you know,
maybe it's a bad look.
We've all seen people that get attention or that get a press or rather fame and
then it goes to their head and they become crazy.
And to become cult leaders,
you know,
it's a bad mix for them.
Right.
You know,
and then other people handle it.
Jimmy Carter style with eloquence and grace like him in a position of power and
influence,
he becomes more introspective,
more,
you know,
more passionate,
more compassionate.
Whereas other people just be,
just start believing their own bullshit.
And like what if there's one out of 100 believes his own bullshit and he's like
ordering us around and like,
oh well this fucking guy.
Well he thinks just because he knows how to grow corn,
he can tell us what to do.
Right?
You develop a whole new set of social issues.
I want to see the first person to become king.
I was on Wikipedia the other day looking at like the queen of England,
I guess.
And I could just keep clicking back in to find the previous ruler.
And I was like,
how far back does this go?
Where's the first guy who one day was like,
Hey,
could you get me that thing?
Why?
Uh,
because I'm kidding.
Yeah,
that's a new thing I just invented.
Like where did that come from?
I want to witness the,
um,
I can imagine all kinds of scenarios.
Like something happened,
you know,
a lightning struck and a tree caught fire and someone said,
I caused that.
Now you all have to obey me.
I have this like divine authority.
And that's where it came from.
But the idea of the,
the leaders emerging that way,
maybe they just were the strongest person.
I don't know.
It probably definitely started off with who couldn't fuck everybody up.
It probably started off with who can pick up the heaviest sword?
Who's the biggest,
yeah,
it has.
I mean that's how it is in the primate world.
If we run it to go back to the primate world,
the Alpha is the one with the most sharpest teeth,
the biggest muscles,
the,
the largest body.
I mean that's,
that's what they are.
If you go to champs,
if you go to lions,
if you go to any,
any animal that doesn't have a language,
that's the,
there's the leader of the tribe,
there's the Alpha lion that comes in and all the male lions have to scatter
until he's challenged by a new young lion.
And then he's forced into exile and has to fend for himself.
Right?
Happens with wolves.
It happens with all sorts of primates.
You know,
the,
the Alpha being that,
I mean,
the,
the one leader and that also probably serves a function of the one leader serves
it's function of,
there has to be some sort of competition in order for them to continue to
progress.
And so this competition for,
for breeding rights,
you know,
ensure strength and diversity.
You know,
this competition also manifest itself when it comes to the human world.
If one can figure out how to dominate all that,
well that's an interesting trait and you can get some shit done if you could
figure that out.
But then others need to challenge this one because you know why?
You know,
it can't be stagnant.
There has to be new new challenges in new competition.
And then everybody will have to elevate their game accordingly because of this.
And that's sort of eventually what leads us to 2014 [inaudible] America.
I mean,
that's essentially what's going on right now.
Right here we are sort of,
but now it's become bizarre and it's not really one,
it's one that's a figurehead,
which is controlled by other giant groups of individuals,
which would call corporations and military industrial complex and all these
different various points of influence that are trying to change the course of
how things are done in order to benefit themselves or their group.
And that means it's essentially like Alpha male shit,
but on this really bizarre and distorted scale.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's really just the same as monkeys,
right?
It's that,
yeah.
Sharp tea analogy is very,
very clear.
Yeah.
But also constantly in competition and moving forward.
And there's folks that want to say,
well,
that competition should stop and this is all terrible and morally and ethically.
Absolutely.
I agree with you 100% for the sake of the human race.
Sure.
For the sake of children and education and poverty.
Absolutely.
I'm with you,
but as an objective observer that's standing back and looking at what has got us
to this point,
it has been all of that.
It has been all this competition for dominance.
It's been all this weird alpha stuff.
I mean that's what's,
that's what's led to this point,
having these conversations.
Stan sitting over a laptop and talking on the Internet and it was some really
fascinating people.
I had to figure this out and there had to be a certain amount of compensation
for their efforts,
like Microsoft achieve this global dominance as this gigantic promoter of,
of,
of computers because of the,
this is a massive amount of reward involved in that Bill Gates is $93 billion.
I mean it wasn't,
this wasn't entirely altruistic.
People can talk.
All they want about Bill Gates is the amount of money he's given to charity and
he's $93 billion.
You really need to have some huge charitable programs going on because otherwise
you're just gonna look,
when I'm honest,
when I was a kid,
it was always like,
can I just write bill gates to me $1 million?
Like that's such a small amount of his is his net worth?
Couldn't you just give me a million?
Would be awesome.
What could you imagine being a guy that has that kind of money running into
people?
Like I'm not that kind of rich by any stretch of the imagination,
but I constantly run into people that want me to fund their projects.
Yeah.
And there's not enough time in the world to engage these people and become a
part of their life and their world.
So they just want you to just like,
listen,
you don't have to be involved.
Just give me the money and I'll get the fuck outta here,
man.
You gotta get your own money.
Like,
I don't have time for this.
Like this is,
well,
you don't even have to think about it.
But I would because I would,
if I gave you money,
I'd be thinking about like,
and I don't,
I'm not involved in your project,
but I'm minuscule in comparison to a guy like Bill Gates.
Right.
I,
I think it really is true that the whole story,
but if Bill Gates walked down the street and saw a quarter in the street and he
like got went out of his way to pick it up,
he would lose money.
If we found $100 who was this money?
$100.
It would cost him more time.
Yes.
Of his time.
And you need,
or the folded it and put it in his wallet.
I don't have the time for that shit.
Can you imagine being so,
so important and valuable that like just folding your own money is not worth it?
Well also there's a weird thing of you become this bizarre target.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're a bank.
You're a walking bank.
Yeah.
Like all someone have to do is grab Bill Gates and lock them in a room and say,
listen,
I'll let you out man,
but I need $1 million for him.
That's nothing,
right?
$1 million when you have 93,000 million.
Yeah.
I mean obviously he doesn't have like a bank account with that much cause he
could withdraw a lot of the other assets and it's not,
it's not all liquid.
But I wonder,
yeah,
if,
if we asked him to just produce by the end of this week,
a pile of cash,
how big of a pile of cash could he produce in a week?
How much would that change someone's life or a group of people's lives or a
community's life?
If Bill Gates decided,
okay,
I'm going to create utopia,
I'm going to go to Tijuana and I'm going to buy it,
I'm going to buy everything.
How much would it cost to buy everything in Tor
free one and have them all agree to this,
hire everyone and give everyone like healthy,
organic food and set up farms,
give people really high paying jobs and like build,
rebuild the entire infrastructure.
And could he create a utopia with $93 billion or is that not enough?
You
could do something awesome.
Uh,
I don't think people would accept the utopia that always find a reason to be
unhappy with it.
Always want to be the alpha.
Yeah.
That it was gonna be the Bill Gates boss.
$1 million.
Do you know how,
what $1 million it looks like?
Yeah.
There's an image of what $1 million looks like in stacks of hundreds would a
billion looks like and what a trillion.
A trillion is fucking a trillion is a lot a isn't,
you know,
it's not as much as you would think.
Yeah.
I've always wanted to do an episode about that and like actually work with a
bank and go to like the vault and say,
could I show people $1 million in hundreds and how it's,
I think it's,
I think that's just like five reams of paper towel.
Like that kind of stacks.
That's a million.
Well,
$10,000 is a small amount.
Yeah.
In hundred dollar bills,
it's not that much.
Right.
You know,
10 hundreds is 1,010 stacks of that is ten thousand ten thousand.
It's not that much.
And so when you look at a million and stacks of hundreds,
it's a relatively small pile.
Yeah.
And a billion gets pretty big.
But a trillion is where shit gets really weird.
The thing about five reams of paper might be for dollar bills.
I didn't come prepared for all these little perspectives,
but yeah,
$1 million.
It's less less dollars than you would think in a,
in breaking bad.
The big pile of money.
That was insane.
Here's the,
here's the image.
This is a what it looks like.
Um,
what is that?
That small one.
A,
that's a million.
That's a million at small stacks and million.
I said a billion.
That's 100 million.
Wow.
1 billion.
That's a billion.
And here's a trillion car.
Poway and those are double stacks.
Yeah.
It's essentially a football field filled with cash and it's stacked up.
You know,
like Shaquille O'Neal.
Hi.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fucking money.
Have you ever seen those,
um,
images of those Mexican drug lords?
They bust,
they go to their house and they have like a whole room filled under dollars.
Yeah.
There's guys like didn't have banks,
they just have stacks and stacks of money and getting plated gun.
And often it's in multiple currencies.
They've got dollars and euros and in pounds and all because drugs are illegal.
Yeah,
yeah.
Forget.
Well,
you know,
it's really tough to like,
do I got really into money laundering during a breaking bad?
I like was obsessed with coming up with the best way to,
to,
to make money look legitimate.
What's the best way?
Well,
I feel like,
you know,
running something like a strip club is pretty good because the clients are
unlikely to really ever want to tell a lot about how much they spent and what
they spent it on.
So you could easily say,
yeah,
I made $1 million last year at my strip club.
Like I dare you to find the clients that,
that and,
and,
and account for all of this and cash in it.
And they would pay in cash.
Right,
right.
Um,
but also I was wondering what about just being like a life coach.
I could just say,
oh yeah,
someone paid me $1 million to teach them how to be happier.
Like you had that,
but that's a write off.
Someone paid you a million,
they would be able to write that off.
It's like educational expenses,
isn't it?
Coaching.
So,
so you're saying the strip clubs still a better way.
There's a batch of money.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Especially cause it's cash.
But then here's,
yeah,
you've,
you've got to get,
make that money.
Look clean.
Just keeping stacks of it in your house means that maybe you could totally go
for like nice dinners all the time,
but you can't buy a house very easily if,
if everyone just goes,
well,
how are you paying for this?
I have a room full of cash that I don't want a bank to know that I have.
Could you please do business with me?
It's tough.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
we're running into this issue in Colorado with medical marijuana and then
becoming a recreational marijuana rather becoming a legal,
and then banks were not accepting the money from these.
Oh No.
Yeah.
And so they didn't,
they couldn't use credit cards.
They had to do everything in cash,
and then they would have to take that cash and they would have to take it when
it reaches a certain amount,
they would have to buy bank notes.
So I'd have to bring that money to the bank and cashing.
Yeah,
and exchange it.
So you have,
essentially,
you have these workers,
you know,
I don't know how much you're paying them per hour with a driving around with
insane amounts of money that's not safe.
It's very unsafe and very easily targeted.
Yeah.
I mean there's just giant medical marijuana take the money.
Well,
because the federal government,
the federal government is not allowing marijuana.
Not only that,
here's where it gets really tricky.
And this is important for anybody who's listening to this that lives in
Washington state or lives in Colorado,
where as a state,
marijuana is legal federally,
still not legal.
So if you go into a national park and you're in a national park and you smoke
Colorado or Colorado people getting arrested,
they're getting arrested by federal authorities.
I should know more about this.
This is fascinating.
Yeah.
So the banks,
because they're federally insured,
can well,
can't the bank just not ask where the money
from?
I guess we tag the,
no,
I think you have to.
I think you have to be able to report it because otherwise you're,
you're helping a binding drug dealers,
what they do in Florida and cocaine,
cocaine,
cowboys style.
That's a long time ago and that's a good question because they,
they did it illegally.
There's more,
there's more banks per capita in Florida than anywhere else in the world.
No kidding.
In Miami.
Yeah.
And they think that that is essentially because of the cocaine industry and that
Miami,
the cocaine cowboys,
which is a fantastic documentary by my friend Billy Corbin.
I've got to watch that.
Cowboys one and two.
It's great.
And we've been going back and forth on Twitter.
I've got to get that guy on the podcast because he's a really interesting guy on
his own and his documentaries are fantastic.
But cocaine cowboys is,
in my opinion,
the very best documentary ever on how crazy cocaine was in Miami at one time.
The entire graduating class of the police department.
They either wound up dead or in jail,
man,
like there was so much corruption.
Everyone
was selling coke,
everyone was doing coke.
Everyone.
The money was coming in in such insane piles and it was so unmanageable that
banks were popping up left and right to launder it.
People were just fucking coke dop and doing crazy shit like Scarface was really
sort of a minor version of what was really going on.
The reality was crazier than Tony Montana.
Tony Montana was very mild in comparison to the actual,
the actual dealings and craziness that was going on during the eighties the
cocaine days.
Wow.
It's amazing.
It's a fantastic documentary
and also all because of the fact that it was illegal.
I mean,
the same thing that's going on in Mexico right now,
they kind of put the Kibosh on it in America or at least slowed it down
considerably,
but the reason why all this illegal violence was going on in the first place or
violence is going on in the first place was because it was illegal.
Yeah,
it was totally,
criminals could sell it and then they had to compete for dominance.
Right.
And you had no cash all around and houses and stuff.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This guy who was a pilot,
he used to have these a holes that he dug in his backyard and we'd put garbage
bags filled with like $1 million right in his backyard.
Most money cash you've ever held?
I haven't really held a lot.
Yeah,
I was thinking a couple thousand
I think I've missed.
Yeah,
I think 2000 I bought a couch with cash ones because there was like,
it was this weird deal that sounds so weird now,
but it was like,
well you know,
if you pay in cash it's like $200 less.
And I'm like,
really?
So I just went to the bank and I'm like,
I can I get 2000 cash or whatever it was.
And then they put it in an envelope and I walked back across the street and
bought the couch with the cash
and that's because they have like credit card fees.
Like,
I've had people ask me if I could pay with a visa instead of American Express
because American Express would give you like a higher fee.
Ah,
yeah.
I've been to to uh,
like bars that don't accept American Express.
Yeah.
Just purely because they hate the feed or something.
I don't know.
I'm not talking about anything.
I know anything.
I think that's what it is.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I've,
I have seen that before.
I've had people say to me,
is it,
do you have visa?
Like we take this,
if you don't,
it's okay.
I'm like,
well why don't you want it?
And then they'll tell you,
well,
they kill you with the fees.
I was like,
oh,
I didn't know that.
It varies
in American Express is always a weird one too,
because it was one where you paid it all off at the end of the month,
which I liked.
You know,
it wasn't like a visa card where say if you owe 1000 bucks,
you pay 10 a month.
It wasn't that.
It was like,
Yo,
if you spend 1000 bucks at the end of the month,
here's your bill.
It's 1000 bucks.
Which I like to just take care of that.
I don't,
I don't want that floating over.
I've been in debt before and it's a gross feeling to have this money just like
sitting over your head.
So the American Express thing,
I liked that you paid it off,
but I guess they charged more for that because otherwise why would it benefit
someone to pay in cash?
Like why would they want you to give them cash?
We can also involved.
Yeah.
Well with cash they could just pretend they wouldn't have to even pay tax on it.
They could just say,
and you're going illegal.
I'm not going illegal.
You're trying to figure out the legitimate reason for it could have been the
fees would have to be right.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm going to forget all the details about this,
but I'm now remembering that I think I had $5,000 in my hand once because I was
investing this money in,
um,
a strip called Roth Ira.
Okay.
And I didn't have any checks with me.
I had checks in some other city and I'm like,
well how else am I going to give this $5,000 I so I got the cash and then turns
out you can't just show up at the cash to invest in the Roth Ira.
So I'm like,
ah,
okay.
Crutch hamp.
No,
they,
they wouldn't even accept it.
And I was told by the,
the wealth management company that if you do that,
they don't want people coming in and out carrying lots of cash because that can
then cause like problems and outside where people know that people coming into
this business carrying lots of cash.
Huh.
So they wouldn't accept it.
So I had to just go and order more checks,
but I now I had $5,000 I had to put back in the bank.
Um,
and my mom did it for me.
This is what I'm not understanding why this story is so weird.
But she tried to do it in the bank,
flipped out and they were like,
well,
where did you get this money?
And she had to fill out a form and like tell them how she got it and what her
job was and why she had all this money in cash.
Wow.
Yeah.
Bizarre.
We had a guy on recently,
um,
who was a,
a,
a poker pro and he was talking about poker players who come back from other
countries and they win these poker tournaments.
Thousands of dollars and a lot of times it gets taken from them at the border
because they don't believe that they won this plan.
You have to prove that you right,
you've got $50,000 on you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You're a fucking drug dealer.
Like,
no,
I'm a professional poker player.
I won a tournament.
Here's my paperwork.
You,
Nope,
you've got to go to court.
And they would force them to go forward to try to get their money back.
They'd essentially steal their money and then make the,
but why would they have their poker winnings from a professional poker game in
cash?
Wouldn't you get it?
Well,
because you get it cashed out.
Like,
say if you're in Macau or something like that,
you win some gigantic poker.
Yeah.
You know thing?
You get your money and then you cash out cash in your chips.
They give you like in Vegas,
like I have a friend who's a degenerate gambler,
but he's also super wealthy.
So he,
uh,
he's Dana White.
He owns the UFC.
He's one of the owners of the UFC.
It's worth stupid amounts of money,
but he'll gamble and win $1 million in a night to hay and they give it to him in
garbage bags.
Like he has to go out to eat.
He goes out to his car,
they grab bags and they feel like $1 million.
They fill a garbage bag up with money and he'll leave with $1 million in cash in
a bag.
Oh,
he's talked about it many times talking about it on the podcast.
They would direct deposit it,
wouldn't they?
Nope.
They give it to you in cash.
Wow.
I don't know if you want cash.
I don't know if they can direct deposit.
I'm not a gambler.
I don't understand.
I don't know any of this.
The most I've ever gambled on something is I think maybe a thousand dollars on
multiple bets.
Like before I used to be the commentator for the UFC.
Yeah.
I would bet on fights.
Okay.
And usually wasn't even the UFC,
it was like other organizations.
And I would go in and I kind of had an inside line.
Like there's still to this day I have a friend.
Um,
and uh,
I give him picks.
Like whenever the fights go,
like I go,
oh,
this is a lock,
this is a lock.
This is the bullshit of this.
These odds are idiots.
I don't know how this got in.
Like there's odds to this day that are really bad,
really.
Like you'll be guy who's a two to one favorite and you really should be a five
to one underdog happens all the time.
And it's because in order to understand mixed martial arts on a very,
very high level,
you have to have some competition.
You have to have competed,
you have to train,
you have to do it on a regular basis and you have to know the people.
And you have to know them inside and out.
You have to know what they're capable of.
If they're front runners,
there's certain people that will fold.
There's certain people that,
you know,
there's certain people that just have an intangible quality that they know how
to pull things off.
And that's how you sort of formulate the odds.
And a lot of times the odds makers are fat old white dudes who really don't know
what the fuck's going on.
They just know based on,
you know,
like this guy's more popular,
this guy's more famous or this guy,
he's beaten a lot of tough guys.
Like they don't know the other guy he's fighting.
Like,
um,
there's certain guys when they enter into the UFC for the first time,
the,
you know,
like a lot of people don't know how they did in other organizations.
That's when you can get sort of the best odds.
And so interesting,
this friend of mine,
I've given them these pigs,
we're like way over 80%,
like way over 80% winning.
So if I was,
if I was a real gambling man,
you know,
I'm not just cause I don't trust myself,
but if I was a real gambling man,
I would,
uh,
I'd be fucking killing them with that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's fascinating.
Who does get to set odds?
They have to be pretty smart,
but they're not,
they're not.
Some of them are,
some of them are smart,
you know,
I don't know who does it.
I don't know the people.
I used to know the guy who did it for USA Today,
um,
very smart guy.
And it was really interesting talking to him about odds.
But again,
an older guy didn't train,
you know,
didn't fight.
He was very knowledgeable.
But I think there's certain levels,
there's certain levels of understanding.
And then at the ultimate level of understanding,
like there's a certain guys who are like,
you know what,
if the shit hits the fan,
I think this guy folds up and you gotta you gotta take that into consideration
when he's fighting the guy who's not going to fold up.
But odds are very big.
Like,
I don't get,
how do you fucking make odds on a football game?
Like you're gonna,
you're gonna bet that these who like you have to follow injuries,
you have to make sure how's his ankle.
I heard that guy's going to bad ankle,
what's going on with his neck?
And this guy has got some new surgery for his fucking hip.
And um,
okay,
take that into consideration.
And this guy dropped the ball last week going,
we've got to factor that,
that,
and there's x amount of players on this team and y amount of players on that
team.
And they're all trying to move a ball across the line with all these random
variables.
It's not just who's going to win and who's going to lose,
but it's like by how many points.
Yeah.
And they're right so often know their rights.
So what my friend Joey Diaz,
as you never see a bookie with a part or the part time job.
That's Joey.
Yeah,
the,
I don't get it.
But when you would think about it,
like if people can understand the stock market,
which they sorta can,
and there's so much money involved in the stock market,
they would be able to figure out the variables involved in any sort of athletic
gambling too.
If there's money involved,
someone's going to try to do really well at it.
Uh,
like insurance is that way.
You know,
there's a bunch of people that are way smarter than you who were cranking away
at machines going,
what should we charge to make sure that we come out of this?
Well,
yeah.
And how do we fuck these people over when they do win or they do have a
legitimate claim,
how do we draw it out?
So we make as much money in interest during the time where we,
oh yeah.
While they're waiting.
Yeah.
I mean that's what they do.
That's why they,
I mean,
the more and the more they can get you to give up.
some people just give up when faced with adversity,
faced with a challenge,
like,
you know,
you're gonna have to dispute this claim.
Ah,
fuck.
A lot of people just give up.
They just fold up shop.
Maybe they're just picking their battles.
Right.
They're like,
look,
it's not even worth it to me to fight this one.
I'm going to save that energy for something else.
Well,
there's,
there's definitely that.
And there's other people that go,
you know what?
I don't see,
I don't care if it's cost me $1 million to win 100,000.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people.
Those people are dangerous.
I had a great experience with the,
my,
my cell phone.
Uh,
it was,
it was a stolen I think.
And uh,
uh,
yeah,
insurance fixed it all up.
I'm just got a new phone.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause I mean,
I was paying for it though,
right?
I paid for like the best insurance,
like replacement policy and all I had to do is go in and say,
yeah,
this honestly was,
was stolen.
I,
you know,
I'm not lying to you check a box.
And then the next day they mailed me a brand new phone.
Well,
it's really crazy is people that have jewelry and they enjoy it.
I know a woman who lost a very expensive diamond ring and she filed an insurance
claim,
got paid and then found it in a jacket pocket.
So what do you do?
I don't know what she did.
I don't know her that well.
She was a friend of a friend but she apparent,
I hope she gave the money back cause if she gets caught she's like wealthy woman
right there.
She gets caught.
She's fucked.
Like they,
you know,
this was like $1,000
ring or something crazy like that giant fat rock and she founded in her jacket
pocket.
Like I think years later,
like she had made the claim and the whole deal and gotten paid.
Right.
She thought that some workers stolen.
Which definitely happened.
And then you find out that you,
you haven't actually committed fraud though,
right?
Unless you decide to not tell them right away that you found the ring and give
the money back.
But isn't it amazing that you could just do that?
You can just say,
someone stole my ring.
Yeah.
He can't prove who you file a police report and then you get the money.
And then you could just put the ring on and the darkness like fucking column.
Right,
right.
Well,
that's how I felt because this,
this phone,
uh,
I know where I left it and it was kind of in a public place and then it was
gone.
And I'm like,
ah,
I'm really sure I left it here.
I'm sure it was taken.
Why would someone take a phone though too?
Everyone's phone has a lock on it.
When you,
what are you going to do with that thing?
Cute.
Well,
I mean,
you can just like reset the whole thing.
Find my phone.
You know,
especially with iPhones.
Fucking mean people have been busted before.
Yeah.
That's,
that's happened many times.
And had a TSA worker got busted because they stole an iPad.
Yeah.
Good.
Fuck them fucking criminals.
And I took it.
Yeah.
And they found it and they went,
they traced it to the person's house.
I watched the episode where the guy's like,
yeah,
you know why there's an iPad in here?
And he's like,
what?
No,
it's my wife's.
And they're like,
well,
yeah.
No,
it's not.
That was really awkward.
Yeah.
Super Awkward.
Um,
how do they,
what do they do with android phones?
They have a similar,
yeah,
yeah.
They do like a find my phone feature.
Yeah.
Um,
and I've been using this thing called Google now,
which is a really pretty fun.
Uh,
I usually never update things.
I never allow things to know my location,
you know?
But this one I'm like,
I'm going to just see what it does.
And it was able to determine where I lived,
where my girlfriend lived.
It knows that I like,
like Taco Bell,
so it'll just tell me when I come to new cities,
it's like,
okay,
there's a Taco bell eight minutes away.
Uh,
here's the conversion between currency,
usually spend in the currency that they use where you are now,
here's some things that you might want to do based on where you're standing.
And I'm like,
whoa.
It's getting really squirrely with Google.
I love it.
I love it for convenience.
But man,
if you ever did something illegal,
like you're fucked by who?
I said,
if you ever did something illegal,
we wanted to track your whereabouts.
Like,
Oh,
you're not,
you mean it's all documented nuts that we are carrying around devices that tell
our locations in speeds or speeds.
Speeds.
Yeah.
If you're speeding permanent from your cell phone.
That's a fact.
As you clip these different stations,
these different cell ports or whatever they are.
Channels.
Yeah.
Towers Towers.
Right.
Satellites.
Yeah.
Well cause you're that you're a gps is all satellite base so even if you have no
connection you can still use the gps to know your location.
That's true.
Yeah.
It used to be that
ps,
was that on your phone?
Essentially?
It was.
It doesn't usually calculating it from,
but it was calculating it from cell phone towers.
Now it's straight.
I'm sure there's different ways that it works,
but I know that like when I was in the,
the radio quiet zone in West Virginia,
there's no cell phone service but a satellite and gps worked.
Oh.
Because they're not talking with the same signals that are like band out there.
I said yeah,
the interfering with measurement times on the information.
Cause I know the old cell phones didn't work.
The GPS didn't work.
The navigation didn't work when you had no sir.
I think it can pull up.
You know where you are and how fast you're moving,
but you need the data plan to get the like images of the ground and the roads
and the where's the nearest thing that's all from data I think.
I mean it depends on what your plan is and what device you're using.
But this is going to come a time where you're not going to be able to drive.
It's coming really soon.
That's another Google thing.
These damn Google car self driving cars.
Well it's,
it's,
it's way safer right now.
Half the world take out all the fun.
I had a panic attack on the way here by the way.
Oh yeah.
I was driving and I just all of a sudden thought what if my site disappeared
immediately?
That
and I was going so fast in this car that would be terrible.
And that sort of freaking me out.
That's funny
cause I had a similar dream recently.
It wasn't,
what if my site disappeared is what if I had to navigate without sight.
And this is the strangest fucking dream and I can't believe I'm remembering
this,
but someone,
uh,
I don't know who the person was,
but they were very familiar to me.
They were driving by putting their,
their hand,
uh,
across their eyes and resting it on a mattress.
So they were driving from a mattress looking down like there was no visual
whatsoever.
And then they were steering with their,
and they were like,
you just got to go on your instincts.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like,
and they were,
they were moving a car from like,
without seeing where they were going at all.
I'm like,
how do you know where you're going?
Like,
well,
I know the path and I know how fast I'm going.
I'm like,
oh,
this is so fucking crazy.
And then I woke up,
it was one of those like,
this is just too much.
Uh,
I gotta wake up,
I woke up and for whatever reason I remember this.
But the idea of relying entirely on the sense of sight,
the c one sense that you use to determine where you are and where you're going.
And it was just the craziest thing to me that all this was being done without
it.
And I think of it as to in terms of submarines,
like submarines freaked me the fuck out because there's no windows and those
goddamn things,
it's just a metal tube.
It's relying on radar and you're in the ocean and you're fucking moving around
like all this water pressure and there's rocks around and you have to rely on
this radar.
And if the radar goes out,
you're piloting this huge tube through the ocean with no idea of what's around
you.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Submarines are fucking crazy.
I mean that they figured out how to pilot things with sound and use radar waves
to figure out where objects are and sonar and that's just bizarre.
Yeah,
the it is.
And,
and the,
the suits that we built to like make that all possible or what inspired space
suits?
Um,
never been in a submarine.
How crazy is fucking James Cameron speaking about repairs.
Yeah,
go.
So Richard,
that's like your hobby.
Deepest depths of the earth.
He went to the deepest depths of the,
of the ocean.
He's like the first guy to like do the Mariana trench by himself.
Yeah.
Crazy fuck all.
All to make Avatar to supposedly it as an excuse to make Avatar to uh,
that's clever.
Well that's one of those,
he's one of those guys that were like,
what would you do if you had x amount of money?
Well that's what he would do.
And he's doing it.
Yeah.
I mean a lot of people would say like,
what would you do if you had,
you know,
fucking $50 billion and all the resources in the world and all these engineers
working for you and what would you do?
Well,
I'd probably devise the greatest submarine ever.
I was wondering what are the biggest wishes?
Like if you could just have one wish,
what would you wish for?
What has,
has anyone surveyed the population and been like,
well,
most people actually wished that they could fly or they wish for money or they
wish for x Ray Vision.
Like I want to see a list of the top 10 most wished,
wished,
wishes.
They would probably wish to have infinite wishes.
But isn't that like a trick like in that in a children's book?
Yeah.
You're not allowed to wish for more wishes.
That's always important.
Yeah.
That's the number one caveat.
You're allowed to,
uh,
what would you wish for if it was you?
Well,
great.
Now I'm having to answer this myself.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't you though?
If you're going to ask it,
why wouldn't you try to answer it yourself before you,
you know,
my answer should be that my wish is that there's complete peace on earth and
everyone's happy.
Right?
That's what we'd be.
Yeah.
But you know what,
that's the kind of wish that could easily,
you had to be careful what you wish for.
How long,
right.
For how long and also what does it mean that everyone's happy?
Is it that nothing changes,
but everyone's just has this contentness that won't go away.
Everyone's on Prozac.
Yeah.
It's,
everyone's got cysts.
S and then I'm like,
that's not what I meant.
But,
um,
I dunno.
I don't think flying would be that cool.
It'd be fun.
That kind of,
but it'd be too windy.
I'd have to build a suit.
Yeah.
The ability to teleport.
Yes.
I want to be in New Zealand now.
Yeah.
I'm a New Zealand teleport.
Um,
how many times would you be able to do it?
Would you be able to do it like blinking when you be able to do it as long as
you're alive?
Yeah.
And then also when you teleported would it still be you?
Right.
It's a huge question about teleportation.
It's like,
well,
wait,
if I,
if I assemble a bunch of Adam's somewhere else.
Exactly.
Replicate you.
Is that,
is that you?
Well,
here's the real tricky one.
Um,
our memories,
memories are always very strange,
right?
Our memories of just my memories of yesterday.
Yeah.
Here's a perfect example.
I had a great time yesterday.
I had a,
a really fun podcast.
Then I went and did two comedy shows at two different comedy clubs.
I drove around,
I hung out with my kids.
I had a great yesterday,
but my memory of it is quite sketchy.
I mean,
I can recall things in my head that I'm reasonably sure I did,
but it's pretty sketchy.
And then I went to sleep.
I shut off and I woke up and I woke up with the memory of this life.
And how do I even know that that's all the stuff that really happened?
How do I not know that I just started my life today?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
How can you prove that the universe didn't start 10 seconds ago?
[inaudible] or your life didn't start getting seconds or,
yeah.
Or the very least when you were rose,
when your consciousness,
I mean,
you know for sure,
reasonably sure that you were unconscious,
and then you became conscious this morning and when you became conscious this
morning,
you like,
where am I am in my bed?
Uh,
what time is it?
Let me check my phone.
What's today?
I think it's Wednesday.
Okay.
What do I do today?
Oh,
I've,
I'm Michael from vsauce is a Koan over is going to do a podcast that's going to
be cool.
Okay,
cool.
And I'm assuming based on my memory,
that this is the life that I've chosen and that this is the path that I'm on and
this is the events that are going to take place based on my iPhone calendar or
whatever.
But the reality is it's mostly just memory of a life that I've assumed.
Yeah.
I lived at when I was a kid,
I would freak myself out by just thinking about how I was trapped in my own
mind.
No one else was ever going to see out of my eyes.
No one else was me.
And it really made me feel lonely and trapped.
But isn't that of all the people I could have been seen out of,
out of all the mines,
I could have been on this one.
That's a weird thing to freak out about.
That's a very specific way to look at it.
That you're trapped in your own mind and you felt lonely because you were
trapped in your own mind.
I've never felt that.
I've never,
no one would ever look out of my eyes and be my head.
Well maybe they will you the idea that we can record with a phone.
Yeah.
You know,
you can record video and audio.
You could,
you could,
I could show you some stuff that happened yesterday.
Right?
This is a bird landed on my porch.
Look at,
I took a photo of,
yeah,
there's a video of it.
You can see the bird.
Oh there's the video that's sort of timed capture,
right.
Captured a moment in time.
There's gonna come a point in time where there's a much more sophisticated way
of doing that.
And I think it's going to be based on like some sort of a virtual reality oculus
rift type situation where we're going to have,
whether it'd be a Google Lens,
a contact lens,
or whether it be some sort of a neural implant that's able to accurately record
what you see and what you experience.
And then they're going to take it to the next level and the really advanced
versions of it.
We're going to be able to record a motions and touch and feeling.
And,
and your,
your own,
the battles that you have in your mind of perception,
the battles of a,
is this person being mean or are they just doing their job or how do I,
how do I go with this?
Is this traffic annoying or is it fascinating that there's all these cars,
you know,
what is,
what's my take on this and how do I choose to perceive the world?
Because that's a lot of what the world is,
is the choices that you make in perception.
It's not just the perception itself,
but how do you interpret that perception and what do you decide that it means?
Yeah.
And you know,
maybe you could like have insight as to why a person has fucked up like this.
There's some woe is me,
people that are really annoying.
Like everything is woe is me and there's always happens is bullshit.
And you know,
is it,
could you get in their head and could you find like,
oh,
you've got a hitch here,
right?
And how you look at stuff like you automatically,
you've,
you've developed a pattern where you automatically assume the world's out to get
you.
Yeah.
Like I know a dude and uh,
he's,
I wouldn't say he's smart because he's socially very dumb,
but he collects a lot of information and he believes that he's smart because he
collects a lot of information and collect information mean like he learns facts.
Well,
he runs a podcast and he's a,
he's a conspiracy theorist maximum.
Like he believes in chem trails and anyone who disagrees with them as an idiot,
he's super confrontational about it,
but he thinks that he's really bright.
But anybody who listens to his podcast,
who's objective could say there's something wrong with this guy.
Like he thinks everyone's a CIA disinformation agent.
And like,
it's really,
really bizarre when you listen to it.
Like he's accused me of being a disinflation agent for the CIA or the FBI or
you.
Not Anymore.
Oh,
okay.
It's just some fucking stupid,
but he,
in his mind,
he makes all these connections and he believes these conspiracies abound and
that they're everywhere.
And I would love to see what's wrong with his brain.
I would love to like go on like a schematic tour of the synapses,
how they fire and go,
Oh,
you've got Asperger's.
Oh you got it.
Disease
conspiracies are fascinating.
It's like you can't admit that just stuff happens.
It has to all be part of some plan.
It has to all be controlled by some like organization or person.
Well this is why,
because some of them are real.
This is why conspiracies are fascinating to people.
Like a lot of folks want to be in the no nonsense crowd and they want to say,
well,
you know,
spin spirits.
Either people can admit things just happen.
Okay,
but here's a good one.
Yeah.
Nine 11 do you think that nine 11 happened?
Meaning do you think that planes flew into towers and people died?
Do you think that that happened?
Yeah,
I do.
Okay.
Well then you believe in conspiracies because the,
what's the conspiracy that people can aspire to do that?
Ah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it was very organized events.
Sure,
sure.
But I'm talking about the like things are being hidden from us.
Okay.
Do you believe that the government has tried to hide things from people?
Oh,
they have for sure.
So then they're real and they advance those if of the events have actually taken
place.
If events like,
like operation Northwoods,
you aware of operation Northwoods?
No.
It's one of the ones that conspiracy theorists love to point to because it's
pretty fascinating.
In 1962,
uh,
this was a,
this is signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff and operation Northwoods was a plan
to get the support of the American public for war against Cuba.
And what they were going to do is they were going to blow up a drone airliner.
They're going to blame it on cue.
Ah,
yeah.
Arm.
If you heard this,
I think I'd read about false flag operations,
all these things and I,
that one came up
big ones because it was right around the time where we were considering going to
war with Cuba because Cuba was allied with the Soviets and the whole deal and
they were going to arm Cuban friendlies and attack Guantanamo Bay and kill
American soldiers.
I mean this is a,
there was a whole series of events that they were planning.
This is all vetoed by Kennedy and it was a,
you know,
a real false flag plan.
And if you look at that,
you realize,
well that's how they think.
Like the people that were running the government at that point in time,
at least in 1962 there was a certain faction of them that thinks this way
everything evolves,
including evil.
Everything changes,
evolves,
becomes more complicated,
becomes more,
you know,
they,
they get better,
they innovate everything.
It's just the way things go.
Nothing,
nothing stays.
Still,
everything must elevate including its conspiracies.
Yeah.
I mean if,
if that's the case,
if operation Northwoods was really signed by the Joint Chiefs of staff and the
freedom of Information Act,
the documents that have been released show that it was right.
If that's the case and no one went to jail for that because no one did,
those are fucking criminals.
I mean,
those guys were planning on killing the children of Americans who went over and
we're,
we're working as soldiers believing that they were defending freedom and all
this jazz,
but they were going to be killed by other American soldiers or other American,
you know,
military people who are working in cahoots with the joint chiefs of Staff.
That's crazy.
It's a amazing,
yeah,
amazing fact.
So if that is true,
you,
you look at things like that and you've got to go,
okay,
well of course people believe in conspiracies.
If you don't believe in conspiracies,
I believe your infant tile,
I believe it's,
it's a,
it's a silly thing to think that the government doesn't conspire when you hear
that Dick Cheney and George Bush were considering a false flag attack,
uh,
on,
that they were going to say that Iran had attacked America.
This was something they had considered before they left office.
So the problem is that there are conspiracies,
but then there's another problem is that people see him in everything seem and
things and aren't conspiracy.
It's like you see chem trails,
they believe that con trails that are created when jet engines pass through
certain levels of condensation in the atmosphere is actually the government
spraying artificial clouds over.
Where does that idea begin?
The chem trail idea?
Yeah.
Begins with just,
well,
someone said like,
I feel different now than I did before airplanes flew over.
I wonder if the government created a chemical that makes us all obey them.
Have you ever seen prince talk about it?
No Way.
Prince,
the artists,
the musicians,
the artists was doing an interview.
Yeah.
And in the interview he was talking about chem trails and he was talking about
growing up and that you know,
he,
when he was a kid he would see these trails in the sky and then all of a sudden
everyone would be fighting.
Everyone's fighting and I was like wondering,
they're spraying things is making everybody finding like,
Whoa,
what the fuck are you on prep day?
I don't know.
You'd have to ask him.
You'd have to ask him but it's,
see if we can find that.
It's you got it.
Okay.
We'll,
we'll pull it up because it's quite hilarious.
Like,
like first of all,
no one,
obviously he has formulated this incredibly complex theory that these people are
being quiet,
that thousands of pilots,
hundreds of pilots,
whatever,
engineers,
people that have armed the planes,
all of these people have formulated these methods of distributing some sort of a
unheard of chemical that can cause people to be aggressive and fight and only
target the hood.
You know,
you're 30,000 feet above it.
It's targeted,
but he's formulated this but made no attempt whatsoever to understand a is as
possible be.
Is there a disbursement way method of doing it?
See what are these trails that are in the sky?
What are these artificial clouds that everyone's so freaking out about?
Well,
they're not artificial clouds.
Their clouds that are created artificially.
That's all they are is clouds.
The reason why they look like clouds is because
they are cleaning their water vapor at cloud.
Yeah.
Jet Engine passes through condensation.
It changes because of the jet engine,
the heat of the,
of the engine that's spinning of the turbines.
The whole deal in it.
The reason why it looks like they're spraying clouds is cause they're making
clouds with the engine and it only occurs occasionally.
It only occurs when certain levels of condensation in the atmosphere.
This is all bright,
movable.
The point about the,
what's the simplest explanation?
That's the key thing.
I was like,
you know,
they could have also just puts stuff in the water.
Like why does it have to be such an elaborate conspiracy?
Because they see it.
Yeah.
Mick West who runs debunked.com metal bunk rather.
Um,
he's a former software guy,
made video games and he became fascinated by debunking like a really complex
things like this.
Like we're where people have all these like psychological connections to these
things and he calls it the training wheels of conspiracy theories because you
see them,
you see like what is that?
They sprang things.
What is that?
Like?
It's just a to Ed.
Like God dammit.
But nobody wants to look into it deep enough to,
you know,
to sort of debunk the whole thing.
But yet prince will go on television and have this really detailed idea that he
has in his head.
Well here we'll play it.
Yeah.
Cause he's,
it's quiet cause he's still in the back of my head.
I can't get him out of my buy head.
Where this conversation is.
I'm sorry.
Um,
who have you felt most often like in the ring fighting the record industry?
Like Jack or the opponent?
Oh,
like Jack,
like Jack.
Well,
because I knew I was right.
You know,
we talked about this in our very first interview and conversation together.
Um,
it's obvious now that artists are supposed to own their master recordings.
I mean,
in the future it'll be unconscionable to even think you can take somebodies
creation and claim ownership of it.
See,
unfortunately,
this discussion is going to start to barrel into a discussion about the human
genome and the DNA and all the rest of it.
Um,
when it gets there,
then we're going to be in deep water.
See?
So it's better to start the conversation now before we get into God talk,
you know,
um,
you show this is the right video.
There are four songs and I want to ask you about,
and I did what I have never done before,
which is to actually print these lyrics out.
Some of them just to record is so new.
I'm learning some of them I got just skipping ahead a little bit.
Some of the fucking list
more about all of us because,
um,
what he said affects all of them.
He said online or wherever and try to get a copy of it and just listen to it.
Okay.
You're going to listen to this before.
This is not the right shit,
right?
Find the right shit whale.
Um,
the,
um,
there is a video is that video and it is in that conversation that talks about
Kim trail,
but I see what he said that like,
you know,
the genome and the DNA,
like people will throw around big words like fascinating scientific terms like
that when they're talking about really ridiculous shit and you go,
okay,
well you've,
you've researched enough that you understand that there's a thing called DNA and
there's a thing called the human genome is very complex program that has been
devised to understand the,
the ingredients,
the very components of human life,
but yet you haven't looked at all into this whole plane spraying fake clouds
thing.
Yeah.
Enough to understand that.
First of all,
they think it's like aluminum and Barium.
Well,
aluminum and Barium doesn't look like water vapor.
Do you understand that?
Like if they were spraying aluminum and me saying this right now,
I will be accused of being a disinfect paid this information age just because I
simply,
I believe there are real conspiracies.
I believe there's a real threat to security,
peace,
prosperity in this world,
but it's not planes making fake clouds.
You know?
And if people really want to look at chem trails and the dangers of these jets,
look at all the instances of diseases where people live close to airports.
That's the real issue.
The real issue when it comes to air travel is the fact that this is not a free
ride.
No one rides for free in any way,
shape or form.
And when you're burning propellant and that it,
it gets dispersed through the atmosphere.
The people that are on the ground there breathing that shit.
And if you breathe that shit,
that's the real danger there.
The real concern is not these artificial clouds.
The real concern is the fact that you're burning fuel in the sky at a rate of
thousands and thousands of flights a day.
Yeah,
that's what's going on there.
There's a direct correlation between lung diseases and instances of asthma and
all directly related to people living close to airports.
I mean that's,
that's the real chem trails.
I mean that's real.
There's really are burning fuel and it's just pollution and it's not a special
chemical designed by the government.
Who was the government like I got like five guys all in a room where like don't
tell the rest of the reptile people that don't tell the rest of the planet,
but we've created a chemical that will make people want to fight because did you
find the Jamie?
Okay,
here it goes.
This is a,
this is one of my most favorite clips,
phenomena of chem trails.
And you know,
when I was a kid,
I used to see these trails in the sky all the time.
And so that's cool.
A jet just went over and then you started to see a whole bunch of,
and next thing you know in your neighborhood was fighting and arguing.
And you did know why.
Okay.
And,
and you really didn't know why.
I mean everybody was fighting.
So he,
he started riffing about the chem trails and
he started to say things that,
uh,
hit home so hard.
And I would recommend that everybody try to get what he said online or wherever
and try to get a copy of it and just listen to it because the uh,
I was so moved that I had to write the song.
Are you write about Kim Jones?
First of all,
if,
if that hits home move.
Okay.
If that's,
if that hits home,
these chem trail,
these,
these planes are making people fight,
you need to move to a new home because your home is retarded.
I want to hear this song.
I don't want to hear the song.
I love Prince and he's got some great songs but he's a complex dude,
was filled with emotions and not a lot of critical thinking when it comes to
things like this.
You know,
the idea that somebody told him some nonsense and now you know,
in his defense pre-internet,
that was a lot of the ways that information was shared.
I mean,
how many conversations were happening?
Dude,
did you hear that the government is doing this thing and some of them,
some of them are so ridiculous,
they seem to like conspiracies.
But our real like the gay bomb.
Did you ever hear about the gay bomb?
I've heard things like it.
Yeah.
You got the government actively tried to figure out a way to make a bomb where
they could ignite it in the air or blow it up in the air,
detonate it rather.
And it would cause everyone on the ground to fall in love with each other and
write gay and that they would lose the will to fight.
Right?
Yeah.
That was like a real plant.
But yeah,
before,
before the,
um,
the internet and like mobile phones,
you couldn't easily just like fact check stuff people told you.
So urban legends,
I think we're way easier to spread.
They still spread.
But,
but it's like if you would just bother to look it up,
easily find it.
That's not true.
But when I was a kid,
the,
the thing with the girl in the hot dogs and that,
well it did happen.
It happened right here.
I'm just coming out when the story is this.
It's a little,
it's a little graphic,
but please a girl gets it,
gets a hot dog stuck insider.
And
it wasn't until I grew up that I started talking from people with people who
grew up in different cities and they all knew the same story about this girl.
And it's like,
wait a second,
right.
This never happened.
Or maybe it has happened,
but this wasn't something that happened in our Mike Unity.
Yeah.
Well that's a story when,
when someone ever,
when someone creates like,
uh,
like even something that really have,
like I had a buddy who,
um,
he's an ophthalmologist and he did his residency in Miami during the cocaine
years and uh,
he dealt with a lot of really crazy stuff.
Like he saw sure.
Gunshot wounds and all,
but he said by far the craziest things that were the most like,
wait,
what?
Where people with things stuck up their ass.
Yeah.
And he said like everything you can imagine,
electric toothbrushes,
light bulbs,
like they pulled out of people's asses.
Like,
if you can imagine it,
like the urban legends pale in comparison to the actual truth of fit pistols.
They found a pistol that was stopped at this guy's ass.
Yeah.
They stuffed a fucking 38 caliber pistol in his ass.
If you think about fisting,
someone can fist yeah,
if you can fit that and your,
but you can fit a lot of stuff.
You could fit a gun.
Yeah.
And did he do that for fun or was it a punishment or is he trying to like sneak
the gun?
A good question.
I don't think he's going to be honest.
Yeah.
Why do you have a pistol up your ass?
Well,
the government is paying,
it was on my ass.
I don't know.
You know,
but the reality of pistols in your ass that mean that that's as bout as bizarre
as that durable,
rich Richard Gere German.
I remember that.
Right?
Yeah.
But when I first heard that story,
I had no way of confirming or denying it.
I,
it was just a story.
Well,
I can give you a story on that story.
I don't know if this is true,
but what I had heard was that this was when Richard Gere had left Scientology
and that one of the ways they got back at him was treating this.
How do you release that story though?
I don't know,
but my friends to know,
I would like to know too.
It might not even be true,
but my friend Eddie grew up in La and I grew up in Boston and we met when we
were both in our like 30 years and we had both heard the same rumor growing up.
So somehow or another that's it.
Yeah.
Numer got across the continent.
That's what I'm saying.
I heard these rumors,
like I,
I,
I had friends who told me a story about a famous,
a fried chicken place in Chicago and this woman like goes up there and orders a
bunch of food,
like a lot like,
like eight chickens.
Right.
And,
and there's this funny conversation that they have a,
and it ends with the woman going,
you don't know my life.
And everyone told this like,
you know,
I was told that this happened in this like restaurant.
Four years later I'm driving around with his person who grew up in New York.
She tells me the same story and I'm like,
what is this?
Just one of those things where everyone has a friend who saw this happen.
Right?
Which is really strange when you stop and think about the length of time between
religious stories being told over campfires and through oral traditions and them
actually being written down somewhere.
Yeah.
Ha.
Because if that story about the woman at the chicken restaurant,
which I didn't even tell very well,
but it's not even very funny,
but it's just that story was accepted as fact.
Yeah.
A specific fact that occurred at a specific restaurant and then I realized that
it's just everyone has a friend who had this experience.
Well,
Hawaii is incredibly fascinating to me.
A one because it's just so beautiful and two because it's a volcano that sort of
popped out of the middle of the Pacific Ocean,
the most remote spot on earth,
in fact,
so remote.
It's incredible.
I love it.
It's my favorite place to visit.
But when I was there,
I was talking to this guy.
I went on this fishing trip and,
uh,
the guy who was the,
the captain a boat really cool guy was telling me about,
uh,
he,
actually grew up in California and then made its way out to Hawaiian,
decided to stay there.
And we were talking about the local traditions and the local,
uh,
the,
the folk lore involving like how the islands were formed,
how the stars were formed and all their stuff was like in songs.
And,
you know,
their whole history was just oral tradition.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a people,
you know,
the Polynesian people settled in Hawaii,
first of people whose entire history was this,
the,
these very,
very important stories that they told to each other,
but they never really wrote them down.
Yeah.
Incredible.
And like the stars were sewn together by the God.
Right.
And the maps they came up with were really,
really cool.
Yeah.
Um,
I was just talking to someone about how the,
the native New Zealanders put south up in their maps.
Hmm.
Right.
Not North.
And so if you,
if you actually look at New Zealand upside down,
it looks like a fish and all this kind of thing.
Uh,
and that's,
that's what they thought their land was.
It was this fish that was coming out of a boat or whatever it is.
Um,
and then we came and said,
no,
no north the other way.
It doesn't look like a fish.
We decided,
we decided that north was up.
Yeah.
It's so subjective too.
We've stopped to think about like what's up and what's down.
Like if the universe is this huge,
giant,
infinite thing and we're on a ball,
who are you to say which way is up?
The whole thing is circular.
It's spinning,
it's spinning around another ball.
And that ball is a part of a giant cluster that's spinning around at Cirque
wipeout.
Fuck.
How do you know what up is which way up when we can agree that it's gotta be one
of two places.
Right?
Cause there are polls that we,
that we were spinning around.
Yes,
but which ones north in which one?
South meaning,
which one should we put up?
It's just a matter of convention that needs maps easier to read.
If you tried
Rita upside down map,
which exist,
we're all the letters can be red,
but the,
but the land masses are upside down.
It's very confusing,
I'm sure.
But if you're standing in the south pole up as above you,
that's up.
Yeah.
In every direction you faces north.
There is no east or west
standing on the South Pole.
What?
Yeah.
How's that work?
Well,
you've run out of east [inaudible]
because there's no,
there's no more,
there's no more circle around the earth.
Now you're just at a point.
Oh,
I see.
And so yeah,
there's a famous puzzle about this and I think it goes something like a hunter
walks,
um,
you know,
10 feet south and then 10 feet east and 10 feet north and he's back where he
began.
What color was the bear he shot.
Huh?
And the answer is white because he's clearly at the North Pole.
That's the only way you could make,
you could do that walking like go south,
go east,
go north and you're back where you started.
It would have to be at the North Pole.
Right.
But how could there not be an east?
Cause if you're standing,
let's say you're standing at the very point of the North Pole,
the very top.
If you travel east,
you can't,
you have to go south a little bit first before you could go east.
Oh,
it's,
it's finished.
Go sideways when that tape now that would be north.
Oh,
I see.
I see what you're saying.
I'm saying you were saying like East,
west,
forget wires.
A circle.
Would you have to go though before you could go east a step?
Yeah.
You'd have to go,
we'd have to define what's the smallest amount of distance you could travel and
still say that you moved.
Hmm.
Yeah,
because like I would say an inch or less,
I got the tiniest amount and then you go east.
Yeah.
I mean we're,
we're,
if we measure millimeters and how,
how precisely I remeasuring the point that is the north or South Pole.
Because if you're on that point,
your body is already bigger than the point.
So you can put,
you know,
but you need that.
You need to get away from it so that you can go around what the,
what's going to happen.
Maybe you can answer this.
Maybe can't,
what is gonna happen if the polls shift?
I don't know.
I haven't,
I haven't actually read a lot about what that could cause it.
It could be like a y two k thing where it's like no one even notices and they're
like,
oh,
but it could also mess stuff up I guess.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
What about animals that,
that can detect a magnetic fields and use it to navigate?
Are they going to be all freaked out?
What animals do that?
I think some migratory birds do.
That's what they do.
They detect magnetic.
Yeah,
I think so.
What the fuck?
Like rather than having the same five typical senses we have,
they've got one for magnets.
Bazaar.
Yeah.
How is that even possible that they feel they have a magnet in their head had
tells them where,
you know,
that's what like woodsmen always,
uh,
talk about like real outdoors,
the true north,
like having a good compass and also they use it as sort of an analogy to morals.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I understand.
True north,
you know,
this moral compass that they have,
it's very similar to the compass that an animal must have or a bird.
There are also cultures that don't have words for left and right.
Everything is just a,
uh,
north,
south,
east or west.
Really.
Yeah.
So you would never say,
hey,
could you give me that thing that's on your left?
You'd say,
Oh,
could you give me that thing that south of you,
what culture are those?
I think it's an aboriginal culture in Australia.
And so
this is falls into the PSAP.
You're worth hypothesis that like the words that you have changed how you can
think.
And if you lived in a culture that did not have the award for left and right,
are you like less individualistic because things aren't defined by you?
They're defined by the earth.
It's either north or south regardless of which way you face.
Whereas in our society,
like left changes,
my left changes according to me and so therefore like individual people's
perspectives matter and define how I talk about things in the environment.
That's fascinating because left and right,
we associate with handedness,
whereas east and West is [inaudible] position on the map
does always east no matter which way I faced,
but left my left is changing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
But if you're facing,
if you're talking about stage right,
would you talk about West
or would you talk about east?
Uh Oh well it would depend how,
which way the stage was built.
Well,
I say we'll stage is a weird like,
like say if you were in a building and then I said,
hey man,
go,
go east.
Would you need a compass?
No.
Like they just always know which way north is
because it's so important.
They don't have a word for left and right.
Right.
I don't know how to answer this one,
but how do you describe left and right to some someone who has never heard of
those concepts?
My kids,
you know,
I have a six year old and a four year old and I tried to describe left and right
and uh,
my daughter,
one of the ways that I,
I mean this doesn't make any sense other than showing her because um,
I say,
um,
make the letter l with your hand and the one that looks like analysis your left.
No,
the one that points like say if it,
is it pointing,
if like this is what I say,
like if you're looking at me,
yeah.
And you're,
you're writing,
you know like say you're writing the name of Laura.
Yeah.
Like where's your thumb pointing?
That's pointing towards your left and if you hold your hand up and your hand
makes an l see where your index finger,
that's the law.
That's the left.
So this one's pointing to the left.
This one is the left.
But you've got to make sure that you're not looking at your hands,
palms facing because then then the Ellis made by the right hand.
Yeah.
So if you hold your hand up,
I guess,
and that is the l like if forms it,
that's the one that is the Ale.
So if you hold your hand up and you see an l in front of you,
that's the,
that's the left,
right?
And if it's holding your other hand up and it's making an l to the other person,
but that's confusing.
Like get it little kid to write on a window,
like the one,
like a steamy,
like if they're taking a shower,
right.
Your name so that I could read it.
Did they get that?
No,
they always write it the wrong way.
And then you got to show him how to deal with the other way and they go,
oh,
okay.
But it's so squirrely in their head.
It's like,
oh,
like
fascinating how kids,
Eh,
have to develop some of these,
uh,
ideas about the world,
like the,
the old,
uh,
um,
constancy of volume or what does it really called?
Um,
uh,
that things stay the way they are when you're not looking like a really small
kid will even think that.
Like when they don't see you,
you're gone.
Like peekaboo was a really terrifying and,
and an amazing game to a child.
Yeah,
I vary.
I'm talking like a baby.
Right.
Um,
but then,
uh,
look this up on,
on youtube the,
they show an experiment where you take two different size containers.
One's really tall and skinny and one's short and fat and the tall skinny ones
full of water.
And then they pour the water into the other container and they're like,
which one has more water than like,
which one's bigger now?
And clearly the same amount of water is still there.
You just saw them pour the water.
No water was taken away.
Right?
But a kid doesn't get that yet.
They think that,
oh well it's not nearly as tall,
this other glass,
so there's must be less water.
And they'll grill the kid like,
well,
where'd the water go?
And the kid won't even know,
but will insist that there's less water now because it looks smaller.
Is that a perception thing?
Like an animal thing,
like larger,
taller things are more dangerous?
Sure,
sure.
That it's,
it's like that's what matters.
And it takes a while to understand the,
the less needed for survival process of realizing,
oh,
that's actually stayed constant.
That kind of makes sense when you think about how animals will make themselves
look bigger.
Yeah.
Like they,
their hair sticks up on it back in order to give them a sense of,
or an appearance of having more mass.
Yeah.
You know,
rowing,
yeah.
Bears will stand up on their hind legs and they tell people,
like if you're in you,
you encounter certain animals like mountain lions,
you should make,
make yourself look bigger.
Like wave your arms get larger.
If you have someone with you,
like a child,
put them on your show Lau and make it look like it's a bigger thing.
Right?
Yeah.
Like it's like a appear more of a,
a larger tricks.
The animal.
Yeah.
They're dumb as shit.
They're Dominican.
It's fun to watch these kid experiments because you're like,
oh wow,
kids are dumb.
They think that,
you know,
this is,
uh,
any,
any idiot could tell Ya.
Well,
it's not that they're dumb,
it's that they haven't come across this problem yet to solve.
So they don't have the data yet.
Exactly.
Like there's a difference between dom and a lack of data.
When you have a person and they're 50 years old and they still think that the
world is flat and they still think the earth is 6,000 years old and they still
think,
well that's a dumb person.
That's like,
they're the data,
they've probably been exposed to the evidence,
they be exposed to 50 years of Western civilization and their perceptions of
life are,
it's insane.
Yeah.
Given the data that's available,
that's a dumb person,
but a baby's just this bundle of potential that just,
that doesn't have any data yet.
And so they're just acting on,
you know,
like,
well what seems to make sense from an evolutionary standpoint or from a genetic
standpoint,
their animal instincts.
Very bizarre.
The idea also,
the idea that this is all changing and growing and then your children will have
the benefit of the information that you've accumulated over your life,
like through epigenetics,
and it's going to somehow or another pass to your children and they'll want to
know about the head.
I don't know about that either.
Hmm.
Well,
they say that certain things like even racism can be passed down to children.
You mean genetically,
genetically,
chemically.
Yeah.
I don't,
I haven't seen a lot of evidence for that kind of stuff.
But there was a famous experiment where a guy taught worms to move through a
maze and then he like ground them up and fed them to some other worms and those
worms like knew how to solve the maze without having to be taught.
But it's never been replicated.
But wouldn't that be cool if we found out that there was like a chemical basis
from Emory?
That would be amazing.
Yeah.
Well they have shown that,
um,
they've taken,
I believe it was mice and they used a certain smell and when that certain smell
was introduced to the mice,
they gave them a chemical shock or they gave them electrical shock on their feet
and the children of those mice when exposed to that smells like a citrusy smell.
They would have a panic attack.
Really.
They would have this panicky moment where they anticipated being shocked.
Huh.
Because it was programmed in their DNA that that smell equals danger.
That smell equals pain or discomfort,
right?
Yeah.
So,
so that's different than just natural selection.
Where do you say,
well,
the,
the mice that just naturally didn't like that smell.
We're the ones that lived longer procreated more.
And so that's why
I think that's probably true as well.
Yeah.
I think it's one of those things like when we're talking about conspiracies,
you know,
while people,
can it just be a random coincidence?
Yes,
it can be,
but there's also evidence that people can spire,
right?
So there's both,
and we have this tendency to want to wrap things up in a nice,
neat little bow.
So the,
the concept of natural selection will,
there's natural selection.
This is very simple to explain its natural selection.
No natural selection is a factor.
That's also a fight.
It's not like it's nonexistent.
It,
no,
that happens as well.
But then there's also this weirdness is his weirdness where information is
transferred.
Like I've done Jujitsu since I was 1996 is when I started so in and I've also
been a commentator for more than a thousand professional fights.
I probably seen more mixed martial arts fights then most of the population ever
will in real life too.
And my kids,
when I watch them roll around,
when they watched them play,
especially my youngest,
she has instinctive moves that I don't think our natural moves like when they're
rolling around my,
my,
like there's a thing called the over under and it's what you do when you,
when you take someone's back taking someone's back is you'd gain an advantageous
position by being behind them and controlling their body in a way that they can
attack you,
but you can attack that.
You're forced into a very defensive position and they're in a very dominant spot
and the over under is one arm over shoulder,
one on under the armpit and you clasp your hands together and it's a very
dominant mode of control.
But it's not,
I don't think it's instinctual,
but my daughter goes to it immediate huh?
When my daughter,
who's who was three at the time when she was rolling around playing on the bed
with my,
on my,
um,
at the time,
five-year-old,
she would go over under all the time and then she would throw her legs around
and get her hooks in,
like instinctually being to do it.
He said these are like traditional Jujitsu positions and I think that it's in
her DNA.
I really do.
I'm like,
watch your took them out.
I watched her go from side control to the mount.
She slid her knee across the belly.
She did it like Jujitsu style.
Like I don't think that that's a natural thing to have like baby to have to do
some more experiments,
take a look at her genome.
I really think that it's instinctual and also like I've teaching them striking
and the way they learn it,
it's like they're learning and like they already knew it.
It's really weird.
They're learning,
like pivoting off the ball of their feet and throwing their weight into things.
It seems totally natural to them.
It's very strange.
I think if you catch people young enough,
they're still plastic enough that they,
they'll just get it.
Uh,
like language for instance.
And you know,
I learned English.
How long did it take me to learn English?
How long?
Maybe two years until you started talking about like when was I fluent enough?
Someone would say like,
yeah,
you'd pass a test.
Well is also is a weird thing where people say that their youngest learns
quicker because the youngest is around only adults.
So the youngest is sort of like forced to like try to be,
or like the things that they're around,
whereas the oldest has younger people around.
Exactly.
Whereas if your,
uh,
or the not the youngest,
I mean like the first born,
not the youngest I should say,
a learns quickest.
Whereas the,
um,
the ones that are born later,
they have all these little people that talk,
you know,
like babies around and takes a little longer to figure out how to communicate
like an adult.
Yeah.
The first born was like,
oh,
I'm the only kid here.
A better,
yeah,
yeah.
Pick it up.
Yeah.
You have to be like,
you have to imitate your atmosphere.
Okay.
Where you a firstborn?
Yeah.
Siblings.
Yes.
I have an older or younger sister.
Okay.
Me Too of younger sister dude.
We're like wow.
Crazy.
I'm probably the only ones,
probably the only two guys who have younger sisters who would have thought,
uh,
yeah,
I'm going to have to pee again.
I this is incredible.
You can do it.
Yeah,
I can do
it.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Go Pee.
You promise you're not.
Yeah.
You already know you're going to judge me when I even say look at that guy.
He just can't even do that.
You're a slave to his by judge you.
It will be highly good.
Okay,
good,
good.
Excellent.
So we'll um,
we only have about 15 minutes left anyway before we turn into a pumpkin.
This is a fascinating conversation and if your highest fuck right now,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for freaking you out.
Me.
Um,
these kind of conversations are always really cool though.
Whenever you're a involved in a conversation where you're sitting with someone
who you've never talked to before and you start going over weird shit like
genetics and what causes a person to be this and that and what,
what,
what are the steps that you take to become a human being?
And it's also like our rudimentary knowledge of wha how,
how he,
like when he was talking about,
uh,
we're,
we're talking about learn things and how much of it is natural selection and
then you find out things like the,
the mouse test where they,
they know that mice associate that sense of smell,
that smelling that thing with an electrical shock.
Even though these mice have never experienced that electrical shock,
it was their parents doing it.
Like that's pretty clear evidence that there's something being transmitted
through genetics.
Whatever it is,
they don't know.
But we'll know someday.
Someday we'll be like,
oh well that's,
yeah,
they definitely,
like we've found,
we've isolated the genes that cause people to transmit certain bits of
information to their children that are useful.
Like right now we're,
we're not much different than the people that we mock from a long time ago.
The thought that the earth was the center of the universe,
you know,
like the amount of information that we have.
I was just saying that as you're back from your potty break,
oh,
it feels so much better.
I'm sure the amount of information that we have today is kind of akin to like
we,
we mock like people that lived in Galileo's time for not knowing that he was
correct,
that the earth was not the center of the universe.
You know,
we're like God out.
They pulled the torture,
the poor guy,
you know,
or,
or Bruno for the saying that the universe is infinite.
They burned them alive.
Right,
right.
You know,
and we think,
God,
this is so stupid,
but what we know now,
whenever you're alive,
the,
at that point in time is the greatest moment of knowledge in human history.
It is,
right?
Yeah.
And you think,
Oh wow,
so glad I'm here and not in the past,
but not giving and taking you collapses of civilizations,
which is her story entirely.
Well,
yeah,
it's tough.
It's a little more complicated,
but yeah.
But yeah,
it's not linear entirely,
but it's Kinda like an up and down up and it's progressive.
So at this point in time,
you know,
when we're talking about information being transferred from parents to children
and we're like,
I wonder,
I mean it natural selection.
I went,
but we don't,
we don't know it was one day,
whether it's a thousand years from now or whatever it is,
they're going to go,
oh,
those dummies.
They didn't even know.
I
know.
Look at this,
we've got audio recording of Michael Stevens Sane.
I don't know.
I think,
I think so.
Maybe natural selection.
And they're like,
that idiot fucking prince.
He thinks that they're spraying shit
over the ghetto and making people fight.
No,
Duh.
But you know,
it's just,
uh,
it's just one of those things is information progresses.
We'll find out
that,
that this lava lamp,
by the ways,
huge that's in this room.
It takes a long time to warm up.
Yeah.
Well,
this podcast is almost three hours old and Jamie,
you probably switched it on half hour before the show.
Yeah,
it takes a few hours,
but look at the little ones,
little ones up and cooking.
That's cooking really well.
Wow.
That's a great lava lamp.
This big one,
um,
never really gets going.
We need to shut up to leave it on all night,
all day.
Then Shit could go wrong.
Yeah.
We had one that had a crack in it.
Oh yeah.
We noticed it.
Where like,
is that a crack?
Then we had to learn,
you know,
lava lamps are used to generate random numbers and they can generate them very,
very well.
They're very difficult to find patterns in the,
if you,
I don't know how they do it,
but they,
they'll look at the shapes and movement of a lava lamp and that'll generate
numbers and they don't have patterns in them.
Really?
Yeah,
so you know you can go to like random.org.
I just did an episode on what really is random and random.org uses atmospheric
noise,
just noise in the atmosphere,
like radio static to generate numbers.
Pretty good lava lamps.
There used to be a website that had a lava lamp and you would type in,
give me random number and it would be based on the state of the lava lamp.
Give you a random number.
Uh,
so if you watched a lava lamp,
so if we had that lava lamp on and we maintain the same amount of heat coming
off of the light bulb in the same water temperature and the,
yeah,
but you,
but you don't though.
That's,
that's what makes it so random.
The,
the initial conditions are so difficult to know precisely enough to predict
which way it's going to float the temperature.
We only know the temperature to like a few degrees,
you know,
uh,
or,
or a 10th of a degree,
but that,
that millions of a degree difference is what's going to make it move now rather
than neck.
Then in the next second,
you know,
possible to make an ultimate lava lamp that was incredibly precise.
So the amount of heat that comes off of the bowl was really like really precise.
The amount,
the temperature of the water was incredibly stable.
The consistency of the wax was uniform throughout and that you set this like
perfectly measured lava lamp with the glass being the exact same diameter or the
exact same thickness rather over the entire circumference of the,
of the bottle that holds the water and the wax.
And would it be possible to make an ultimate precise lava lamp?
Well,
it would you,
you could predict it better.
I still don't think that it would be precise,
like symmetric all the time unless you put in special controls that like didn't
release the wax until it was ready or whatever.
Is it the,
the wax moving up and through the water,
which changes the temperature of,
of the wax because it's not in contact with the heat at the bottom.
Are you asking what makes it so unpredictable?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's just like every little movement of those blobs is affecting all the other
molecules inside that system and those are affecting how something moves later.
It's like a butterfly flapping its wings causing a tornado in Brazil,
you know?
Yeah.
But that doesn't really work that way.
That's sort of dopey.
I hate that butter.
The Butterfly flapping the wings of a butterfly.
No,
but it eventually lead to be a hurricane.
it can't really because no,
it's true.
Whether it does its patterns,
they caused that,
right?
We're not going to be able to know like,
Hey,
have that butterfly flaps its wings.
That'll cause a tornado,
right?
It's just the point is that that little difference in initial conditions could
result in a completely dramatically different outcome.
You can do this with a double pendulum and it's pretty insane.
You,
you,
you put two pendulums up and you release them and it feels like you dropped him
from the same place and you can use a robot to do this and everything,
but after just a few seconds,
they're both spinning completely differently from one another.
It doesn't mean that the butterfly will always be causing tornadoes.
It just means that you,
you,
you have no idea how many variables are,
are,
are involved in and one little thing changes another little thing and that can
cause an end result that is way bigger and way more different than if the
butterfly hadn't flapped its wings.
Really.
So Butterfly flapping its wings really can put into motion a chain of events
that could lead to a changing of a weather pattern.
Weather patterns.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
What does a butterfly effect when it flaps its wings?
This is more of like a,
yeah,
it,
this isn't like we've studied it and we found a butterfly and we blamed him for
Hurricane Sandy Butterfly.
Yeah.
It's more like the,
the principal is that a law,
that little tiny,
um,
movement of air caused some larger massive air to actually,
you know,
move a bit more and,
and,
and this all stair steps up
to the point where the hurricane could happen.
Another example would be knowing the position of the earth in,
in billions of years or just millions of years,
hundreds of thousands.
We can only really predict where it's going to be and,
and,
and we're,
all the other planets will be so far into the future.
And even though those systems are pretty,
you know,
it's going in a circle around the sun,
like that's it,
right?
Yeah.
We should be able to guess.
Right.
But at a certain point,
we don't know.
We don't have enough information.
Uh,
just,
just launching a satellite causes the earth to spend a little more slowly
changes its position a little bit.
Really.
The,
this the APP.
Yes.
So Neil bring off,
yeah.
Yeah.
Neil degrasse Tyson did a great calculation and in his book,
um,
death by black hole,
I think,
uh,
where he says,
yeah,
he just,
just what it took to send up that satellite never comes back down
means that earth is going to be
a few degrees in some different direction in a million years.
And we don't know which direction that's going to be unless we,
unless we have an incredible amount of information about that satellite and how
it affected earth when it left.
So
every single piece plays a part there.
Every single variable,
every movement plays a part in the ultimate end result.
Totally.
Yeah.
And that's what makes the weather so difficult to predict.
Find a lava lamp,
butterflies and shit and lava lamps fucking up in the lightning storms.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yo,
we're always trips me out that ancient people were able to figure out the
procession of the equinox.
Right.
Like every day they were just like checking like,
yeah,
yeah.
Same time of day has somehow I knew that it was the same time,
time of day and I marked it.
Or maybe what do they do?
They just watch and see where the sun was when it was at its highest point.
Make a little mark somehow and then they realize,
hey,
it's going in this like a loop thing.
Well,
not only that,
the loop,
isn't it like thousands of years,
like the wobble.
The full wow.
Right,
right,
right.
Like what is the,
I don't know actually.
It's a really long amount of time.
Yeah.
The procession of the equinoxes procession.
Okay.
Um,
I wanna I want to say it's thousands of years,
but I don't remember the exact 26,000 year cycle.
Wow.
So they figured out a 26,000 year cycle,
pretty good measurement to see a change year to year.
That was just one 26000th.
Yeah.
That's one of the ways that these,
um,
a lot of these,
revisionists of ancient Egyptian history point to the possibility besides the
erosion of the Sphinx pointed the possibility of the Sphinx is far older than we
think it is.
Um,
is that at 10,500 BC,
it was pointing towards the Constellation.
Leo At this lion was representative of this,
this constellation that has sort of been universally described as being
associated with a line because of its shape.
Okay.
This is the reason why they believe that 10,005,
both sides of the fact that there's all this water erosion around the sphinx
that can only be attributed to thousands of years of rainfall.
And the last time there was rainfall and the Nile Valley was 9,000 BC,
which they think,
you know,
they think that they want to attribute to the Sphinx to the same people that
they believe built the pyramids,
which is about 2,500 BC.
But they think that actually there might have been many,
many,
many older kingdoms.
Like there's hieroglyphs apparently the date back to 34,000 BC.
I don't know any of this.
Yeah.
They,
they date back as far as their descriptions,
not as far
as like the actual,
uh,
carbon dating and that their descriptions of Pharaoh's go back thousands and
thousands of years.
And so they get to a certain point in time,
the Egyptologists go,
well,
that was just fiction.
Yeah.
You know,
we'll,
we believe in Ramsey's.
We believe in,
you know,
Tut Moses,
we believe in all these different cats,
but the oldest stuff,
that was just the more,
yeah.
That was just horse shit made up.
Yeah.
But if the revisionist historians are correct and the geological evidence is,
it's really fascinating,
especially when it comes to this,
like a guy named Doctor Ron Shock,
Robert Schoch,
uh,
from the university.
Boston University.
Yeah.
He's a geologist and he's the one who sort of spearheaded this whole thing about
the sphinx because he's,
um,
he's a geologist and he's like,
this is clear water erosion around the Sphinx.
And,
um,
they,
uh,
they think that if that is the case,
then these stones had to be cut way,
way earlier than 25.
I need to look into all this.
It's fascinating.
And this procession of the Equinox is this 26,000 year cycle that wobble.
You know the idea is that the earth spins for folks who don't know what we're
talking about.
It doesn't spin in a perfect circle.
It kind of has a little wiggle to it and every 20 well it sort of like a top and
every 26,000 years that wiggles completed.
So the sky looks different through the entire 26,000 year cycle.
Right.
And that's,
that's one of the things that they point to this,
this constellation Leo at 10,500 BC aligning itself with the Sphinx also
coincidentally lines up the 10,500 BC lines up pretty close to what they believe
12,000 years ago was a massive asteroidal impact all over the earth.
Like this nuclear glass,
I think it's called Triton night,
you know that stuff that they find the,
the,
the do core samples and they find it at 12,000 years all over the place.
Evidence of a big impacts and not just a big but multiple.
Okay.
Meteor impacts.
Meteor showers that could have led to the extinction of saber tooth tigers,
woolly mammoths,
all these different animals that died off at a very sick,
very similar time period.
60%,
I think of all land mammals died off during that one time.
Yeah.
Fasa.
What's,
that's the theory that like humans survived.
Some did we didn't have as many predators or no,
no.
The theory is that just this huge interruption of life,
this massive meteor shower that they found all throughout Europe and Asia,
this nuclear glass that's very similar to uh,
the,
the uh,
the type of glass that they find after nuclear detonation tests,
that this nuclear glass,
which exists all over the places indicative of massive impacts that something
happened like,
and it's not in one spot.
It's multiple spots all over the place at the same time,
much more likely to be a meteor shower than anything else.
And that,
that probably was also the cause of the end of the ice age.
And that's what,
uh,
you know,
at 12,000 years ago,
more than half of North America was covered in a mile high sheet of ice.
And so they think that what caused that stuff to rapidly change was most likely
the same thing that caused this nuclear class to be all over the place,
which is a big mind fuck and also coincides with when the Sphinx was around
that,
you know,
it could be that there was a fairly advanced civilization at that point in time,
slammed with meteor showers,
massive amounts of people die and then they sort of have to rebuild and they
kind of learn like what it took them a few thousand years to get back on their
feet and writing.
You know,
a few thousand years later they're building the pyramids again.
I'll have to look into these stories.
That sounds really interesting and also it falls right in line with that whole,
what do you do when you have to start all over again?
How long does it take to get back up to where you were before?
Yeah,
well the idea that has been a linear linear progression,
complete linear progression,
straight line from caveman to us seems a little silly when you see all the
impacts that we know for sure happened.
When you know,
when you look at the Clovis comment,
when you look at all the,
the,
the different,
the Holocene crater,
all these different impacts that they know happened.
They know that this,
you know,
look at the moon,
it's Goddamn shooting gallery.
There's things happen.
And when things do happen,
all these stories like the Noah's Ark Story,
epic of Gilgamesh,
all the different cataclysmic events that have been documented through folklore,
most likely some shit went down.
And that was the idea that that's what freaks me out about hard drives.
That's,
it freaks me out about the idea of everything being stored on computers.
Yeah.
Including this podcast,
including this podcast.
Yeah.
Imagine if someone had to tell this podcast and an oral tradition,
some of that,
take the information that we discussed in this podcast and describe it.
Yeah.
Because they couldn't play the file,
but they heard it before.
They heard it before but then butchered it.
And it wasn't prints.
It was James Brown and,
and you know,
all the,
all the various things that we talked about get all screwed up.
Right.
But still attributed to us.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you would be like some information,
God from the future.
They'd remember the part about you going into the past and they would butcher
that.
He who pees a lot.
Yeah,
he's had a problem.
His bladder wouldn't forget that part.
No.
Yeah.
If you really stop and think we're in the process of something,
we're right in the middle or not even,
we're just,
well,
we're in the middle in,
in that it's going on,
but it's constantly going on.
It was going on when they were single celled organisms.
It was going on when the star Supernova to create carbon,
which created carbon based life,
which created us,
which created everything that came before us,
which going to create everything that comes from us.
Yeah.
That would be,
if I could see something I w I don't think if I had a choice of Chin going a
million years in the future or a million years in the past,
it just for a visual glimpse,
a million years of the past is pretty fascinating,
but a million years in the future to see what a human being looks like a million
years from now.
Yeah.
That's what I would want.
How different would we be?
We,
we have,
okay,
we can change our own bodies a lot more now.
Uh,
and we've made changes unnecessary in a way because we can you,
we have climate controlled buildings and we have vehicles and we have medical
care that can keep things the way they are
better than we'd had 3 million years ago.
Better than we have 300 years ago.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what does a human going to look like in a million years?
I would guess
not that different biologically,
but we'll be doing some pretty crazy stuff,
I would guess.
Radically different.
Yeah.
Well,
I think physically we're very different from people that just lived a couple
hundred years ago because of nutrition.
Sure.
Look at how tiny people were.
Oh my God.
That's what's really weird when you see how little folks were.
Yeah.
Like the average size of people that were fighting in the civil war was like 125
pounds.
Wow.
That was an average man.
There were tiny little dudes,
like people were like 80 pounds bigger on average now.
Right.
Which is really pretty substantial.
Yeah.
But I think that the real change is going to come with our integration of
technology in our lives [inaudible] and the symbiotic relationship that we have
with this technology,
which now you leave your phone behind,
you feel naked eventually it's going to be something much more integrated.
Yeah.
I think that's where things are going to get really squirrely.
Well,
I think where people are going to start to become connected inexorably with this
technology
aliens,
Bro.
That's what we're going to look like.
We're going to look like aliens does.
Yeah.
Think about it.
We ruined our atmosphere.
Okay.
We were fucking holes in the ozone layer.
You need permanent sunglasses,
so what are those big black eyes?
Those are giant sunglasses are built into your head.
No longer need to move things physically because we can do things with
telekinesis.
We have giant heads because our brains are going to grow the same way.
The human brain sides double over a period of 2 million years and you know
ancient proto hominids.
Right.
Our brains are huge compared to our body size.
Yeah.
I mean,
a whale brain is way bigger than our brain,
but whales are also huge and they need all,
um,
all of that for all those extra nerves.
But in our little bodies,
we've got a huge breaks off the charts.
Yeah.
No.
And used to be smaller in other,
other primates and whatever we came became,
you know,
however we became people,
that doubling of the human brain size is a massive mystery,
right?
Aliens,
we're going to look like aliens.
We're going to have these big goofy beach ball heads,
little skinny bodies,
and going to be able to manipulate manner.
Boy,
this fucking conversation got stupid.
I blame me that you were responsible for science and I,
I took us to the wolf stoner stuff.
I was like,
what?
It,
yeah.
What have we w yeah,
we wind up looking like aliens.
I think we'll,
if you think about like a gorilla or an ape or whatever monkey type animal we
used to be,
and this is big stipulation.
People say,
Oh,
you shouldn't see monkeys.
You know,
people aren't monkeys or apes.
Uh,
actually,
no,
we're all monkeys.
This is how it goes.
Um,
all apes or monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
Is that true?
I don't know.
Dislike.
All humans are apes,
but not all apes are humans.
Monkeys,
not a real scientific term.
Ah.
So when you say something's a monkey,
like,
oh,
monkeys have tails.
No,
monkeys aren't even real.
They're sending.
So people who are con who like anal and correct you on that.
Tell him like,
fuck off,
fuck off.
Grammar.
Police.
You're incorrect.
I like that.
It's like,
it's like a is a,
um,
what's a vegetable scientifically?
Because really I think vegetables,
just a made up word for any other part of the plant.
Anything's a vegetable.
That's not a fruit really.
Yeah.
Well because fruit has a scientific definition,
right?
It bears the seeds and it contains the,
you know,
the Inuit,
the energy,
the food,
the,
the seeds need a,
but a vegetable is just,
you know,
it's the root.
In some cases it's the leaves.
In another case,
it's the trunk.
And another case,
what you eat is the vegetable,
right?
Vegetable matter.
Plant matter.
Yeah.
So again,
it's like I can't tell you whether it's a vegetable or not.
Does this go up to like what the chefs,
let's say like tomatoes?
Yeah,
there's a fruit.
Yeah.
They're fruits.
Bananas or are fruits,
but,
but modern bananas don't have seeds in there.
They're not fertile.
They're not going to grow.
You have banana tree.
So should we still call it a fruit?
Well,
from,
from a culinary perspective,
it's pretty fruity.
So we'll call it a fruit.
Yeah.
It's fascinating stuff.
We're out of time.
We could do this forever though.
I think you and I can have these conversations until our heads explode.
Yeah,
I think so.
Until we become alien.
Until my bladder explodes.
Yeah.
Your bladder is not that good dude.
You need to work.
But you drank two big things of water where you're sitting.
Yeah,
I know.
Come on.
Give me some credit.
Like I had both of those and I had one before we even started.
I'm a hydrated guy.
It's very good to be there.
It's very smart.
It's good to be.
Just this morning my urine was a bit dark.
Oh,
I really,
I was like,
nope.
Gotta drink some water.
Will you flying in now?
I've been here for a few days.
Where you boozing it up?
No,
you drinking a lot of coffee.
Yeah.
That could be it.
Energy drinks to those can really fuck you up.
Those will really dehydrate and those aren't good.
Yeah.
Those make me pee more than anything.
I could drink coffee and be fine,
but if I drink one red bull,
I got to pee.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
People don't care about my p listen,
but they do care about mine.
Your Youtube channel is awesome and it's been an honor to have you on the show,
man.
I really,
really appreciate it.
It's really cool talking to you honor to be here.
And uh,
I just think it's so cool that something like what color is a mirror has 10
million views on youtube.
Yeah.
And that's not,
it's not like a standup routine.
I really do get into the,
the physics of,
of reflection and a why the answer is kind of green and it's,
it's an amazing youtube channel and I've found it out because of someone from
Twitter.
So whoever you were on Twitter,
that turned me on to Michael.
Thank you so much because uh,
I've learned a lot and been entertained and educated by your videos and I think
everybody else should as well.
So it's v Sauce,
the s a u c e on Twitter and it's tweet sauce,
tweets,
tweets on Twitter on Youtube.
Excuse me.
Yeah,
the sauce on Youtube.
Tweet sauce on Twitter.
Michael Stevens.
Thank you sir.
Thank you very much in a pleasure.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to blue apron for uh,
for being awesome.
And uh,
you can benefit from blue apron as well.
If you go to blue apron.com forward slash Rogan,
you will get two free meals.
Just go in there,
blue apron.com forward slash Rogen.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com that is o,
n,
n.
I,
t.
Use the code word Rogan,
and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back on Saturday,
a special Saturday edition of the podcast with my pal Abby Martin from our t.
She'll be here and,
uh,
that's it until then.
Enjoy your life.
My friends,
big kiss.
Okay.